the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
started off swimmingly at the Cairns Cup
in Saint Louis catch the best female
chess players in the world Making a
Splash in the capital of Chess in an
event stacked with Elite veterans
newcomer gunai mamanzana is rising above
the tide taking advantage of her
floundering opponent to claim a tie for
first former women's world champion
Alexandra castenick is in top form
netting a win and sinking reigning
Terence cup champ puppy canaros hoax for
a triumphant return four Victors have
floated to the top of the standings can
they ride the wave or will they come
crashing down day two of Titanic chess
coming up next
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone welcome back to the round
two of the Karen's cup I'm here at the
World Chess Hall of Fame and it's a very
beautiful exhibition I certainly hope if
you're in town you'll stop by and check
it out but for now let's go back in
studio and start the action live
welcome to Saint Louis the home of Chess
in America and the third edition of the
Karens cup one of the richest women's
tournaments in chess we come to you live
from the San Luis chess club
[Music]
good morning and welcome thank you for
joining us I am International
and I'm here with Grandmaster yesterday
is always wonderful to have you in
studio to call all the action what a
start that is incredible so many
decisive games amazing jet lag had an
issue there definitely I would say
almost all the players here came from
far away Europe or India so it's going
to take them couple of days to adjust
absolutely hello everyone and Welcome to
our show boy did we start out with a
bang and if you liked tactical fireworks
take a look at that game that Alexandra
won over the defending Champion humpy in
round one it was marvelous and tell us
about the standings after that
great great opening round let's take a
look we have four co-leaders Alexandra
castanoke harika dronavali kunai Mama
Zada and Irina Crush all won their games
yesterday very nice and we had only one
drop between Nana zagnitza and Anna
zatonski absolutely and tell us about
the format for this event right we have
a 10 player round robin tournament
Players are not allowed to offer any
draws and the time control is 90 minutes
for first 40 moves right 30 minutes rest
of the game and 30 second increment from
move one the schedule for the tournament
we have total of nine rounds today the
players will be playing round two and on
Thursday June 8th they're going to get a
rest day and then Sprint to the Finish
absolutely and very fortunate for us
Almira is in studio to tell us all about
yesterday's round America good to see
you bonjour bonjour yes sir
it was quite a spectacle yesterday we
had so many decisive games and actually
I wanted to
to tell you uh the statistics about the
previous events and how it compares to
this year's edition let's have a look at
the numbers well we will also compare it
to sinkhole cup and well I'm sorry Rex
but I think the numbers speak for
themselves so let's have a look at 2019
Kearns cup we had 56 of decisive games
in 2020 it was 51 of the size of games
and so far after the first round in this
year's editions we have 80 percent of
the size of Kings let's have a look at
the centerfold copper statistics so 80
18 that 2019 uh 31 in 2021 and 31 in
2022 so I will ask those gentlemen to
raise up their game so what does it take
actually to win at the
Karen Scott let's have a look at the
results of the last edition of the
current scarf in 2020 the defense and
Champion
she scored six out of nine and this
means that well she won four games and
lost only one
yes sir what do you think we are
expecting uh this year how many points
do you need to win well after that first
round out mirror I'm not sure six might
not be enough but is it okay to say that
humpy's on schedule because she she lost
a game so let's let's have a look lay
the table for our viewers tell us about
the pairings for round two yeah
uh today in round two we have
humpicanero playing the tournament
leader Irina Crush very very nice match
against
who had a bumpy start but she's looking
to recover against Anna satonsky right
Elizabeth pets against kunai mamazada
and two co-leaders caught Sanuk against
Toronto Valley that's got to be a
marquee matchup right there and our
fearless Amazons uh what are they
fighting for they're fighting for a lot
of money the there's total of hundred
and eighty thousand dollars in prizes
that's a very rich price man absolutely
and the first place winners going to win
000 second place thirty five thousand
third twenty five thousand thank you
Jeannie sinkfield all the way down to
10th and final place of six thousand
everybody's going to walk away with a
nice price fund as we see the players
arriving at the World Chess Hall of Fame
right across the street and I love the
Karen's cup gear that they're wearing I
know beautiful blue shirts nice Anna was
the only person the only well the her
game was the only draw uh and uh she
played with Nana yesterday but that
easily could have gone one way or the
other so we almost had all the types of
games Nana definitely had her chances
earlier in the game right but we can
also say some of the games looked like
they were going to be a draw yes and
then they turned out to be decisive now
again our defending Champion okay she
lost but it took a great effort to beat
her and she's looking to bounce back
today but she's playing as you said
against Irina crash it was in great
shape yesterday she won a great game but
she he's starting the tournament with
two blacks so we'll see how she does
today indeed
and this is Bella
Amira jump in uh yesterday
big as you said uh spectacle uh what are
you expecting from the players today
well they calm down or or will it be a
boil well actually I wanted to see if a
Arena crash will be able to keep her
momentum she's playing with black pieces
against hampi conero they our defending
champion and it will be a very important
test I'm very impressed with her game
yesterday and while I was thinking about
the tournament I I think that it's very
important to mention uh that uh in
Karen's cup or in single fold cap you
always have the opportunity
to show the local players the national
heroes and they have this unique chance
to play against the best players in the
world so let's say Irina crash and Anna
zato they have a chance to make a
Grandmaster Norm in this tournament
right
and that's always very very nice to have
those Norm possibilities I am thinking
about Arena and Humpty uh two huge names
in women's chess they're head-to-head
matchups I'm just trying to imagine that
how many games they might have played
against each other because you would
think probably enough enough that they
know each other very very well from all
of these things
there we go and here we go there we do
have a lifetime they have uh five games
total and a happy one twice lost once
and two draws very competitive matchup
between these two these two yes they
might have faced each other at the
olympiads yeah
their country exactly that's that's what
I was thinking I played both of them
actually a long time ago at the world
Blitz Championship oh really how did
they do I beat Arena but I flagged her
in a completely lost position
look you'll take it
it's competition right how about
yourself Amira how have you done against
uh humpy and Arena uh I've played a few
games against the champion and Arena and
especially the game against the arena
one of the last games that I play
against against her at one and that's
when I won my
super tournament and cross note rings so
I have very lovely memories of those but
I suffered a lot against humpicular but
I think that I only lost one classical
game and a few draws all right as we see
you're really getting wanted yes she's
the last one to arrive I remember that
when we played the US Women's
Championship she's always the last one
to arrive
you know why no her secret she likes to
take naps before her games I could never
do that I would be frightened that I
would oversleep same here yeah but it
works for her she comes well rested to
the games impressive impressive and we
do have some games already started
really so uh definitely uh
um a late arrival for arena as we uh
well let's just start I always like to
start with our tournament leaders now
that we have four Alexander kostenyuk
and harika I see this as being at the
Marquee match for the round I mean
Alexandra opened one E4 against uh humpy
one a marvelous game and an open
Sicilian is
promising beckoning us Knight F3
we saw one Sicilian yesterday it was
Irina with the black pieces and she won
a very nice to Rouser absolutely E7 E6
where we see d2d4
as we get a beautiful view of the chess
pieces these chess pieces are really
fantastic pieces from they're from
luxury pieces from the house of salt and
they're triple weighted in their digital
board enabled and they just you sit at
the board and you just feel like you're
you're practicing I love the sets and
the table like you mine yesterday super
professional beautiful and comfortable
dtd4 now harika uh obviously is going to
take is she going to go into a time
enough with A7 A6 which he tried to
which he allow at Keras attack after for
example Knight F6 Knight C3 D6 which you
allow a Charis attack with G4 or would
she try to transpose it into a special
nikoff
tell us uh what is harika's favorite
defenses in uh a sicilian if you know
um Amira actually I'm rather surprised
by harika's choice because I I thought
that she would go for a more solid
opening especially after Alexander's
game yesterday
what I said about the arena is also true
for Alexander and she starts with two
whites the tournament it's very
important there's number one uh seed by
droving of lots she has this privilege
to have more game
more games with white colors so uh E6 uh
I'm I'm not even sure I should have
looked at the database previously but
recently the Four Knights has become
very popular for black so let's say
Knight F6 Knight C3 and Knight C6 but
harika probably goes for uh taimano for
powellson setup we will see a bit later
Knight C6 this is also does invite a
little bit of a wrinkle with Knight B5
just turning our attention to the game
and by the way how do they match up by
Nasi lifetime between these two wow
18 games between them and five wins for
Alexandra four for harika and rest were
thrown while you were doing the math
math I was still getting date
very very very quickly I wanted to just
jump uh to uh the game of between humpy
and Arena Crush because I was more than
curious as uh Amira you said Arena
starting with the two blacks she gets
that from the drawing of lots D2 D4 and
an invitation of the Queen's Gambit
accepted
Queen's Gambit accepted accepted it
takes E2 E4 and right here this is
actually a very intriguing moment
because you know there's two enormously
big branches right here one is E7 E5
right that's one of the absolutely main
lines and you could write a very very
thick book about that and then the move
I've always well always but I'd
preferred uh Knight F6 E5 Knight D5
Bishop takes C4 and it's very common in
these positions to play Knight B6 Bishop
B3 Knight C6 and put a tickle on the
pawn on D4 strangely enough there there
are there are like so many Grand Master
draws I want to say and this is one of
those variations that does lead to a
grand master drone Knight F3 you defend
the pawn on D4 Bishop
to G4 there's this Grand Master draw
that goes like this and I've actually
think I've been victimized or
if you will with this Perpetual check so
uh I highly doubt we're going to see
that today in fact we saw Bishop F fight
no no no Knight B6 but Bishop F5 right
away here uh because I'm a pawn grubber
I have to just give pause for just a
quick moment right Queen B3 yes exactly
I mean that that that move absolutely
flashed in my mind Queen B3 with a
double attack the Knight cannot move
because F7 would be hanging in the
meantime Queen takes B7 so I'm assuming
it's this I miss I'm having said a let
me say B Queen takes B7 I think you're
doing the game prepared she's off the
board she played it quickly and uh
thinking okay so how would it go uh
obviously this is uh this is a taboo
Pond a knight B6 what what what are we
doing here now see why black gave up a
pawn yet well I I'm a pawn Grabber uh
let's let's turn it to Elmira and uh
queen queen B3 has that been played
before uh Amir yes of course it was
played before and especially this is the
latest Trend in the Queen's Gambit
accepted because I played myself so I
heard too of course but the main move is
C6 E6 is less precise so let's have a
look okay because I just wanted to show
you that uh there have been a few very
few games after
um
E6 and queen B7 then Knight B6 of course
but then Bishop B5 you know when your
position is quite delicate then because
you will have to play 98 D7 and
basically what is the reason behind the
the spawn sacrifice is that you will
play C6 here
and they already played they think C6 or
not I don't know I don't have the so uh
normally you cannot take Queen B7 now
because after queen bees after Knight B6
then your queen is going to be trapped
you know you don't will not have many
options here so you will have to try to
find your way where some crazy moves but
then I simply will take your Bishop okay
in order to take this pound here you
first have to take on D5
uh black takes cd5 and you can actually
take the pound on B7 in this way but
look at this powerful Bishop it reminds
me it of the karokan structure of course
or when you will play E6 so black
sacrifices the pounds for the pound for
two Bishops and uh it's well they're
doing quite okay they can even exchange
the queen here you know sometimes but I
think there are a few of Grandmaster
games which were played
um
let me see because they're showing me
the games which were played online and I
was actually looking okay let's see how
it goes Queen C8
Queen C8
Bishop C8
93 E6 and then well let's see we will
try to develop in a normal way then
Knight C6 and actually the computer
thinks that uh White is slightly has a
slightly better position but it it's not
so easy and you know it goes down to the
evaluation to uh plus zero two and you
know when you have a an extra pound this
is very surprising wow um okay uh first
of all the fact that it's not refuted is
already whoa Queen B3 but if I may uh
for a moment I'll mirror c7s a queen B3
yes C7 C6 and I understand what you mean
about Queen takes B7 and then and the
queen might get trapped so I'd like to
include the move Knight C3 again you
can't move the Knight Bishop takes F7
check would be decisive I wanna coax you
into playing the move E7 E6 so that now
now when I take the pawn there'll be no
Bishop C8 trapping my queen has the move
Knight C3 been included in Grand Master
plays uh well let's see I have a few
games that Knights history was played
and is six of course Fallout so after
Queen B7 right I would I can play Knight
B6 and Knight D7 as well because you
well the statistics are rather balanced
here so let's see what happened after 97
right they I even sacrificed the second
pound I guess but if you take this then
night before so you cannot take this
power
yes the nice this kitchen on C6 but I
think what black is trying to get here
is uh really an advancing development
and your queen will have to come back
for your retreat and you know to defend
the fort if I might say for the moment
you know it's not easy so here let's say
what can what can I suggest from a human
perspective let's say if I can try
Knight F3 here and say like I want to
finish the development sure but after
this it's probably a draw you know so
just simply yeah I simply repeat so
there are a lot of Alternatives in this
position and I think it's the matter of
taste for white uh is and be willing to
risk everything in this game or she will
make a choice or something solid okay
but that opportunity for Queen B3 is
caught her eye and she's thinking about
it uh as uh well this is actually an
important game I mean again uh reminding
everybody that humpy started with a loss
and she's playing one of her four
tournament co-leaders what caught you I
just love yesterday how you will come up
with so many ideas just to grab it on
well just to make it work I work with
Victor korchner for a better part of a
year and a half and he walks through the
Gobi desert Barefoot for a pond so I
mean you know like I I learned to
respect those pawns what caught your eye
Elizabeth pets against
my eyes so kunai has one point already
she won the game yesterday this looks
like a super sharp nice to have a night
or yeah
Bishop G5 and old friend you don't see
that so often these days but I remember
a book that Dr John Nunn wrote the
complete
night or if I believe and it was like a
500 page book
part one
Bishop G5 F2 F4 Knight and at One Moment
In The Chess history Queen F3 was the
favorite of everybody
f2f4 became a very popular wrinkle
Knight D7 Bishop E7 uh
and as well as H7 H6 again
huge theoretical debates Knight B8 to D7
became popular uh I've played this with
both colors both colors yes I played it
more often with black I must say queen
E2
um that's also a newer move right as
opposed to Queen F3 and even even crazy
lines with Bishop C4 Queen E2 Queen C7
castles B5
a283 I whenever I was black I always
considered a moral victory that I got to
play B5 and I induced my opponent to
play A3 I always thought the inclusion
of those moves favored the second player
and I don't know about you did you ever
stop during the game to Pat yourself on
the back and say okay
yeah I've already got it yeah Rook B8
okay now is there some lines in Idol
where white can play A4 and now that you
play B5 and I hated those yeah right
you're kind of restrained okay the move
Rook B5 that's absolutely you know the
the Bells Are Ringing uh Black's in
hyper aggressive mode she wants to play
B5 B4 and start blasting open Against
The King and I will point out that
Lisa's time one hour 35 minutes on the
clock wow very well prepared and how do
these two match up uh coming into these
wow play 10 games Elizabeth and yeah
Elizabeth has five wins one loss and
four draws she's looking to win another
yes extend the streak there you have it
and G2 G4
um
Bishop E7 Bishop G2 I see from my
listing there that this is actually very
popular line and both players are still
well in
um the theory uh are you familiar with
this position because this is a kind of
a different wrinkle yeah and I faced H6
okay
how did that go H6 Bishop H4 it wasn't a
classical game so I don't remember it
too well Bishop H4 and I think my
opponent played B4
I'm just pausing because I'm looking at
it yeah it's a pawn okay B4 apologies
you took yes and that Rook takes before
and how did the first of all how did you
do it was a draw but oh man
it is disappointing when night orphans
in a drug right yeah but it was a crazy
game it looks like super double-edged
and I I mean you you've got to produce
the goods here black has to always watch
out for your G5 E5 or F5 moves exactly
because you can play any of them right
yeah okay so cool well let's just jump
at Almera and ask statistically speaking
how do the players fare in this
double-edged super sharp position
uh yesterday I had to look at the
database and actually you have the
position on the board and as he was
speaking about it and actually this
position is already lost for white after
E5 I have issue for white sorry
because I was looking at the statistics
and there without any appeal uh even
took was a little bit uh lucran Valley
and after E5 you are facing a lot of
troubles okay let's see what do you do
after sorry to interrupt I think that's
why in my game H6 was included so that
might okay let's make a difference
because I I just wanted to show the
doctor E5 D takes C5 I do not take only
five but I will play Knight C6 nice and
uh well this is a very dangerous
position so let's say if you will play
Rook B6
here and after 97 okay you lose your
right to Castle and after F takes E5 the
computer evaluates this position as plus
six wow
because Queen takes the desirable Queen
takes E5 will cost you your queen after
Rook takes D7 because the Knight is
pinned and it's a it's a very beautiful
move absolutely but as Nasi was saying
the inclusion therefore of H7 H6 is that
that's what you were about to me yeah
yeah because in that line with H6
included Bishop H4 B4 take I think the
diff in this case now see is that F4 is
hanging right
and in the previous case the bishop was
on G5 so yeah you could win the two
Bishops and prevent me from castling but
that's not the end of the world for
black so I think that's the importance
of the inclusion the move H6 and
sometimes that makes all the difference
in the world as we see Elizabeth at the
board there I I guess she's waiting for
the move H7 H6 yes you are absolutely
right yes sir so age six is a very
important inclusion right then H6 Bishop
H4 then of course I also have a few
games played on the top level and then
you can start with B4 and of course it
takes before Rook takes before and the
same variation doesn't work so I have
um a very interesting move here Bishop
even wow yes the bishop retreats to E1
and creates in a very important threat
Knight D5 so uh well I have a few games
and Max Blue Parham loves this position
very much so he plays it all the time
with white and this is his pet move
Bishop B1 so what does computer think
about this it's slightly better for
white but what
I think from a human perspective it's a
double edged position I think that 3D
results are possible here
so let's say what can you do here Queen
Basics it's it's a very uh I think
natural move you attack the pawn on B2
and okay Knight D5 is no longer possible
and then uh the very strange move now
after Bishop one you play Bishop F2 and
you continuous okay it's a very
complicated complicated game but I
wanted to show you this maneuver Bishop
B1 Bishop F2 then let's say what can
happen after Rook B2 the computer
doesn't react here he goes for E5 I
thought white could play Knight B3 here
after Rook B2 uh that doesn't work right
here can white play Knight V3 to win The
Rook cool let's have a look
you're absolutely right so let's try
this move but then he plays Queen B3
yeah and exchange yes exchange sacrifice
and he thinks that let's say black is
much better here after Knight G4 so you
always have to look uh well to watch out
for this exchange sacrifices even if the
Queens are off the board uh it's uh it's
a very sound alternative
great stuff uh that that game uh
definitely promises to be very very very
yeah we'll keep an eye on it uh just
jump into the game of Bella and Anna for
a second because
you know I'm used to seeing the
so-called King's Indian attack
uh also from a French defense move order
right so d2d3 so this looks like a
French defense uh Council E63 exactly so
now I'm used to seeing C5 E4 and Away
you go and it transposes but as this
move a little bit of a surprise for me
from Anna Knight to C6 E4 takes takes no
more French defense uh the the move E6
E5 and at first blush I'm looking at the
position and I'm going well did you lose
a Tempo somehow with the E4 E5 uh
situations messy jump in this looks like
King's Indian defense except that
Bishop's not Bianca Road right but
reverse I mean right it is reverse
king's Indian right yeah there's a pawn
missing maybe on C5 if the pawn was on
C5 it would really look absolutely what
you're saying my first impression is I'm
not a big fan from Black's point of view
because I see this Knight on C6 doesn't
really have but many options can you
believe this honest playing fast
she's well prepared she's she's always
well prepared people think that because
she thinks so much in the opening she's
not prepared that's never the case right
she just likes to think yeah and she's
kind of making a comparisons a7a5 I
think that move is actually uh quite
important at this moment the move b2b4
is definitely on White's agenda as is
the move Knight C4 what are those moves
doing well they're trying to Target The
Pawn on E5 B4 followed by B5 chase away
the defending Knight gift me the pawn so
the move c2c3 is not only designed to
cover these two squares it's really
designed to protect and Advance the pawn
on B4 so a7a5 I think that's a very
important move now when I was a young
teenager I just
the the the player I worshiped in these
types of structures was it Paul cares he
played them in my estimation better than
anybody in the world and I really liked
uh looking at his games and he most
often would put the queen on C2 in these
positions and play for Rook D1 and
Knight C4 I'm very curious to see uh
what Bella is going to do and how do
they do in their head to head matches
take a look they don't have that many
games just five games and very even
Bella one two Anna one two on one draw
very even
guys and what other games have caught
your eye message uh let's check Nana's
game against shanzaya okay interesting
opening it's uh the English opening but
allowing black to the pawn all the way
to D4 I never liked that how about you
um
it it depends I I was always a very
provocative player I liked making my
opponent uncomfortable some people would
find the move d5d4
discomforting for themselves because
they're not developing the piece let's
put it that way they're leaving their
King in the center that one extra turn
and they are inviting
um you know these kinds of
counter-attacking motions
so yeah I
I must say I I really
sometimes when it didn't always work out
the way I'd hoped uh but yes you're the
point you're making is that if the pawn
actually remains on D4 for a long time
very uncomfortable there you go the
bishop of V2 is saying hey coach you you
know you didn't include me in the game
now what do you think of double fiance
I like them you do yeah I I've always
liked the fiancado especially where the
king is concerned like you know put my
king behind a loyal bodyguard of a
bishop but you didn't play Catalan yes I
played Captain I did okay yeah I've made
I I take great pride in my chess game I
like to say that I've made every mistake
that's possible in Chess at least twice
to confirm it was a mistake the first
time Catalan was one of my great
mistakes I really enjoyed playing
catalans but uh
not always very very well you have to
show me what the mistakes were because I
play
okay there you go right let's just jump
back to uh the game of humpy for a
moment so she didn't play Queen beef
she put the Knight on E2 which I've
always considered rather passive well I
think it's a very interesting setup but
here we have the position where hampi
played the novelty she played Bishop B5
well in order to understand the novelty
I wanted to show you what is the
traditional plan uh you Retreat your
Bishop to B3 right then black normally
plays Knight C6 I played this position a
few times myself so you would develop
your knight to C3 and here actually
black doesn't want to Castle short you
want to play Queen D7 like let's say
Bishop E3 and long castle and it's a
very very double-edged position also
very interesting to play a lot of
different plants and so let's say after
Queen Sivan uh well you can play King B8
then Rook D1 because this this screen is
still uh a bit awkwardly placed on G7
and then you can play Queen E8
um and then with F6 and a very
um sharp play so I think that hampi
wanted to avoid all the lines especially
since she didn't go for Knight B3 for
Queen B3 previously so she decided to
deviate from her opponent's preparation
and I think that Arena plays the Queens
combat accepted for quite a while so she
knows her openings very well especially
it's very important to master all the
plants here so Bishop B5 what does she
want to achieve with Bishop B5 I think
so black doesn't want to play C6 here
because what are you doing with your
knight on B8
so she wants to provoke this move C6 and
then simply Retreat on D3
this is this is uh White's idea or after
Bishop B5 a black has to make a very
difficult Choice do you play Knight C6
here and you allow this structural
change so Bishops it is six uh beat the
X6 you know and you play this position
with Bishop B3 and then 92 Knight B3
let's say Bishop B7 maybe Knight D2 here
and you'll see Castle I just I plan War
of course a lot of moves are possible
here but
um
humpy once a fight
well she's definitely going to get it
but
in my view again I'm a big practitioner
on the black side and I've always wanted
as black to force the trade of light
squared Bishops
I am also thinking that the Knight on E2
is passively placed compared to the
Knight on F3 why do I consider the
Knight on F3 to be important because it
help not only does it help defend E5 but
in many important variations you need to
have possession of the G5 Square so yes
I understand what you were saying that
C7 C6 does step on the square of the
night but what I think is after C6
Bishop takes Queen takes I'm going to
play c65. if your knight was on F3 you
would understand that I'm going to play
Knight C6 and the pawn on E5 would be
defended with the Knight on E on F3 with
the Knight on E2 I'm thinking that I'm
going to play C5 Knight C6 and solve all
my opening problems why why can't Arena
do that
well the computer disagrees with you
okay besides the fact that the computer
is going to refute my ideas what's wrong
it's already plus one for me yes sir
because you're operating you know with
fundamental knowledge and I think
everything is becoming more complete
concrete now so right let's have a look
you have this position on the board yes
and computer makes an amazing move but
which you very often see now in the
Sicilian because now the queen is on G3
what he does he plays Queen G3 first of
all where are you going to develop your
Bishop you know and let's say if you
take on D4 then he brings the Rook into
play so and then okay he says okay My
Sacrifice the pound once again this
exactly this is the way uh well chess
players look at the positions now they
always sacrifice the pound for the long
term initiative right so please simply
ignores it and he plays Knight to three
you see so
so well he thinks that it's already plus
1.2 but I think it's very important to
point out that you are not going to
Castle long here and you don't want to
play G6 here because all the black
squares are going to be weak so let's
say I will make this move you know which
is a very dangerous to make in this
position after Bishop G5 you will still
be forced probably to exchange this
bishop and look have a look at this
Square you know first I can take the
pound and then and then I will let's say
go after Castle I will go 90 right
that's that's be now it becomes White's
Advantage becomes very clear the F6
square is a huge magnet for White's
pieces that I must say queen G3 took me
off uh my stride there completely C5
Queen G3 takes what I thought the
computer was going to do and I was going
to make a very very powerful persuasive
argument historians will call me heroic
but I was about to say that in case you
play Bishop E3 I was going to sacrifice
my queen yeah that looks good eggs for
rook and the bishop and probably a pawn
as well because the Rook would be but
that inclusion of the move Knight C3
no no that wasn't uh not good that was a
very nice inclusion of Knight C3 and as
almero is pointing out G6 Bishop E3 and
I agree in this case uh uh White's uh uh
better development actually speaks
volumes I mean that that's very very
clear nice move Queen G3 didn't see that
one on the board coming so that's maybe
what arena is considering C7 C6 the
desirable C7 C6 uh walks into this queen
G3 and what has she done looks like she
reached for her Knight 96. okay and that
does invite what emlera said which was a
very different
um structure suddenly you've got the
double pawns and just in the variation
that Elmira was pointing out you want to
stop any
c6c5 so you first take the possession of
the C5 Square under control put some
pressure on this Pawn on C6 Flex wide
squared Bishop here I think I would move
it to E4 and D5 like a true karaoke
player you put your light Square Bishop
right there in the center of the board
I'll say also humpy doesn't have to take
on C6 right away nope she can make a
useful move like Knight C3 first okay
there's no rush to take on C6 right
right uh Bishop E7 but then the question
is is are you sure your knight is
actually on the right like I'll just
play another move right Bishop E3
castles now here you really might want
to think about taking the Knight or if
you prefer playing A3 because I think
this Knight is about to jump and you
know you could settle on the D5 Square
you might argue that white has a edge in
space but okay uh
and it's protecting the king too very
important so if ever wide I would have
played Bishop D3 just to get rid of that
Bishop
interesting because I'm always trying to
get I've always been trying to trade off
the light squared Bishop on F5
intriguing
um Amira what uh What uh game has caught
your eye well I was the delphi's Oracle
you know I am analyzing the game between
Alexandria kostinook and Harry cardrona
Valley so I guess they're opening
correctly but uh harika went for the um
uh recently also very
um
popular line Bishop B7 but I wanted to
show you the line which I played when I
was a kid and it might surprise our
viewers you know because the King goes
all the way to F3 and recently there was
a game played by Paulina I think in the
Nicosia Grand Prix and she played a
stunning novelty she played G5 at some
point and the King was on G4 so that's
the spirit of the opening so let's have
a look
um so in this position after Knight E4
harika played Bishop
um
but one of the most important moves in
this position is Queen C7 so Queen C7
attacking the pound on E5 I will have to
play F4 then you play Queen B6 you know
exploiting all the weaknesses after F4
was played C4 I'm attacking this very
powerful knight
so Bishop B4 check and here
unfortunately you cannot play uh Bishop
D2 because of Queen E3 you know and then
gives uh
white a black quite an advantage you
know this is the variation which you
would never play because you look you
lose all of your pounds here so and E5
is very weak exactly so that's why white
is forced to play in this position
very peculiar but probably the only move
can get to right
so now your knight is hanging so what
should you do you will Basics right
Bishop A6 pinning the pawn yes swinging
the pawn so I will uh just a second no
after King it too sorry it was F5 yes
Knight F2 here because I want to drive
this Pawn away and then Bishop A6
um so a lot of games have been played on
the top level recently this uh variation
has been revived by computers when I
stopped playing it it was considered as
completely lost for black so that's how
computers help us to change the prism
and it brings to life these openings so
I have to play now uh King F3 because I
cannot take the Knight and then the the
usual move is to play here 97
so you play Bishop B3
you say Bishop C5
Bishop C5 say queen C5
and then Queen D6 it's very important
not to exchange those Queens so you're
yes so you're getting back to Queen B6
then B3 and so this is considered to be
the Tabby of this variation and well you
play C5 let's say Rook D1
and Bishop B7 a lot of games have been
played but look once again at the
position I'm not surprised that harika
has chosen this variation because it is
really really dangerous for white so
after Bishop B7 you have two moves King
G3 King is three and once again the
three results are possible so I think
that Haruka is also playing for a win
well definitely as both of these players
are actually tied for first so the
outcome we have a view of their clock
right now so Harry has very well
prepared this is one hour and 26 minutes
on her clock I see versus Alexandra
who's really taking her time uh by the
way uh that uh tabia position if you
will all comes from the move Queen C7
which is something that was not essayed
in fact Bishop B7
Bishop E2
C5 castles Queen C7
and Alexandra has just played the move
c2c4 this is the current position the
idea is okay if I'm driving the night
away right let's just pick a square
right here I am assuming this is also
going to suggest before C4 one move back
can white play 96 right away yes
that is also kind of a a standard move
right 96 Bishop takes Pawn takes so you
can't take right you walk into this very
nasty pin on the D file in c2c4 so then
the question is how do you evaluate this
kind of a position right
uh
right and Black's King's not Castle but
my phone is pretty much lost
yeah and somehow there's this nasty
battery I don't know it's it's kind of a
double-edged analyze that with the
engine right you're right a good long
afternoon actually c2c4 so here we pause
because as soon as this Knight moves
then we're hitting the pawn on E5 and
the pawn on e4 but I've got to ask you
the question
here it comes what if I take the pawn
well I wanted to give you plenty of time
to to jump right in so I play Queen
takes E5
now I still don't have an answer
um
captures let's take on D5 let's have a
look captures now we understand we don't
want to Bishop F3 right now we
understand that when this happens this
happens so I've got to keep that
defended if you will so if I take on E6
you're going to take it back on E6 yes
that was the intention yes f e f pardon
me d-e-f-e yeah uh so you can keep that
uh Amira uh and by the way the the
position blew up another way with the
move Knight E3 are you are you about to
tell me we're still in in in
well-charted waters yes we're heads
heads in for the uncharted waters but uh
that's the variation that harika chose
in the game so she played Bishop B7 here
she created it's a very interesting line
so Bishop B2 was played by Alexandra but
it's a very simple move C5 Castle Queen
C7 so uh Alexander played C4 but as you
can see the pawn 95 is on freeze as well
so uh black has to make a decision and
93 was played already on I think on the
it's on the board yes and it was played
uh by quite a few grand Masters but
quite a while ago by Vladimir kramnik as
well but let's have a look at the recent
uh evaluation uh by the computer so you
have to play Bishop B3 here
but you have another option let's say
you can consider uh Knight G6 but after
yes Bishop D6 it takes D6 you don't take
the uh the queen here but you play Queen
C6 here you know and only after Bishop
F3 you will take on D1 you know so let's
say you'll have this opposite color
rook's middle game and Okay computer
thinks that this is slightly better for
black you might tend to agree with him
the castle is let's say it's like how do
you protect the C five pound it's an
indirect protection so Rook C8 for
example if you take here I can simply
take ah no maybe I can win even an
exchange like this or after B3 you know
he he wants to
destroy the pawn structure right so
that's a much better engage so that's
why uh after Knight E3 here uh mostly
every Grandmaster took on E3 so Bishop
B3 we have to take 24.
and now you have two possible moves you
have F4 and you have Bishop F4 so Bishop
F4 was played more often here and well
you can finish your development here
then Castle but computer proposes this
move here a very nice looking movie
sometimes he proposes Queen B7 or even
A5 so you you can stop before here
so these are already uncharted waters
let's say after Bishop F4 the grand
Masters mostly played Bishop E7 and then
well white can play a lot of moves I
think it's the matter of choice white is
slightly better but they think that
harika has sold her opening problems
here all right quick question for you
Almira yes because
as we just review our pairings with the
scores the of the first rounds right so
we have conero playing Crush who is
currently leading the tournament and to
make it clear a canary lost so she's got
the zero Arena ONE version and that's
why she's got the one yes and Technical
has a half Point playing Abdul Malik who
also lost yesterday right Bella with
zero points playing Anna zutonski with
half a point there was the jet black
ballast uh Lisa lost yesterday and he's
she's playing Mama Zara who won her game
yesterday and both castanoke and Toronto
Valley won their games yesterday so so
there's two two of our tournament
leaders playing in this round the
question I had for you Almira is we did
see the move Knight E3 and as you've
been pointing out to us that move is the
theoretical move played by no less a
figure in Vladimir kramnik but Nasi and
I uh did get him intrigued with the move
Queen takes E5 and if Eureka had grabbed
that pawn how would the game have
continued well you should take the
Knight on D5 right and we would take the
Niners you take the Knight on e4 of
course but first of all look at the
position that your Kink is stuck in the
center and the computer is without any
appeal is the things that white is much
better after Bishop F3 but Yasser was
very happy with the extra Pawn thank you
thank you but I was gonna say you look
at my king I look at my extra Pawn I
mean come on I mean look look negotiate
here yes let's have a look maybe you you
will try and no no no not this one I
wanted to play Queen before I wanted I
wanted to show you this movie
I don't I don't like the switch and
ziggs uh my etama producer He Loves Us
wishing Zoo because I don't like them
Queen before Queen before I defend
Bishop did so actually I want to
sacrifice everything of course you
cannot take on me too because of B1 and
you're losing your beautiful Bishop on
B7 that's greedy yeah where are you
going B6 B6 B6 B6 Queen B6 yes and now
once again okay the computer sacrifice
the pound and as you remember he played
Queen G3 in the previous position right
well he's looking at your Pawn on G7
this way Bishop C3 so look at those
Bishops I would compare them you know to
um to the lights in the world you know
there's so you there's nowhere you can
move you know so the laser the lasers
which are controlling the walls right so
that's it 2.6 here so we're here even
considers that the best move in this
position is the long Castle
okay that's uh yeah okay I'm being I'm
being punished for my greed uh the
current position by the way Knight E3
Alexandra's use of the clock suggests to
me that she's falling fallen into a bit
of an opening trap in the sense that uh
harika certainly by the consumption of
the time has
caught her opponent somewhat in a
position her position also as Almira
mentioned it looks like harika sold all
her opening problems exactly now that
that moved Bishop F4 funnily enough was
not my first
uh thought I thought F4 F4 uh to defend
the pawn
and I thought it was going to be like if
you play Bishop E7 and I'm not
suggesting that it's the worst move or
the best move a7a5 is also on top I was
thinking Bishop F3 Bishop F3 Queen takes
F3 uh maybe something like castles and
we get into a position where
is the Pawn on D7 backward or is it just
uh
black is fine after D6 I I wasn't sure
Amira well yes sir you're absolutely
right F4 is a very interesting
alternative to Bishop before and uh
please have a look at the line that you
just demonstrated white is slightly
better and probably what is more
importantly uh black has very little
counter play right you know so you you
still have the possibility yes to play
F5 uh this is the
um not quite a weakness but you will
have to play D6 at some point so it will
be the
will come to the structure with three
pounds against two probably it's about
equal but maybe more unpleasant to play
for black and Europe's from a human
perspective you are absolutely light I
think that you should go for this
position and harika will try to hold it
and actually I was thinking well you
were proposing all the variations when
you're grabbing the phone and the
computer is refuting it it's uh it's we
were talking about the Triumph of the
spirit over matter but I think humans
were supposed to to make this claim and
the computer is making this claim now
it's not always a triumphant by the way
after much hesitation much thought
Knight D6 check was Alexandra's answer
to 93 you did demonstrate the line
Bishop takes D6
E5 takes D6 give me your queen no no no
no give me a Checkmate Queen C6 and we
did look at the line Bishop F3 Knight
takes D1 Bishop takes C6 Bishop takes C6
Rook takes where you felt that slightly
slightly better Bishops of opposite
color middle game end game uh with this
Pawn on D6 uh black has nothing to risk
here right I don't think so I think that
black will say I kind of came out of the
opening pretty okay
um we'll definitely keep an eye on this
one as it's such a marquee matchup in
our games I wanted to go uh back to the
game of Anana of course
a quick second because this was the game
where you had kind of like challenged at
me and said you know like uh on D4 if if
it maintains itself it's going great
peace development looks a little bit
artificial to me okay and if you see
especially night on A3 as well right but
look at this looky looky and you you
said you were a Catalan player you know
what it means one is always on D4 not a
black font there's a wife on it but if
you get Knight C4 95 your cattle and
Bishop you're patting yourself on the
back you're saying well done Nasi I got
this i got this Knight A3 Bishop F5
Knight C4 we're catching up to the
players and I'll make the argument in
favor of white for just a moment that
it's cost you time
to push upon up the board and on a good
day I'm ready to play rookie one take
that pawn and take it again let me play
not necessarily good move no not
necessarily a bad move for you but just
to point out one idea is the E7 Bishop
might end up being
a tactic how you get the D4 Pawn then
yeah yeah exactly so I mean I can see
from Nana's point of view that if the
Knight lands on E5 the bishop on G2 is
happy so you've gotta you gotta kind of
still prove it you know Almira what what
do you think do you prefer white or
black here well it's a very strange
position to evaluate indeed but I have a
piece of information for you they're
still following uh the game between Nana
jagnis she played this exact position
already once again
so let's say Elena was she played Rook
E8 here and Nana took on D4 like Yasser
suggested but computer has another
proposal here so I suspect that Nana
improved on that game so he thinks that
you can play let's say Knight C5 or
Knight fe5 let's see here you will take
here so and he thinks that white is
slightly better here because uh well I
might take on D4 they pound on B7 is
handgun so I think maybe the better
the best reply here is to play Bishop
before and to exchange this powerful
Bishop
it takes D4 or Bishop B4 so it takes D4
let's say C takes D4 and now rookie one
so maybe Nana is uh well heading for
this position which is quite complicated
indeed but maybe she knows it much
better than her opponent right well she
has experience and that always helps uh
to have a
familiarity with the position and I
always felt by the way maybe yourselves
can chime in I'm doing my preparation
I've got my preparation and I get my
preparation on the board but
almost
after the game is over that is the first
time I really feel I understand the
preparation because I've I've now bonded
with it during play it's one thing to
come and say oh when I get this position
I'm going to play Rook B8 and B4 it's
another thing to get into the position
get in the game play Rook ba play B4
make the attack and you go now I get it
yeah that feeling
so many times you know I'm used to
memorizing lines that engine recommends
right but I don't truly understand them
until I get to play them right and
sometimes I know what more I'm supposed
to make but I don't understand it so I
take my times like why am I making this
yeah just help me out here again and
you're right absolutely after the game I
actually truly understand the opening
yeah exactly so I'm just saying that
Nana's played this position before she
probably is feeling that she knows it
and is more comfortable by the way
before I was playing night like in the
current position Bishop F5 Knight C4
before I was jumping with the Knight t
E5 I was including the moves Rook E1 and
why was I doing that because I was
afraid to allow your move Almera Bishop
E4 I like the light Square Bishop I
wanted to keep it on the board for white
I didn't want to allow uh black for
example after Rook to EA Rook to E1
necessarily oops excuse me necessarily
to be able to play Bishop E4 I kind of
wanted to get this and this in if you
include the move rookie one how does the
computer like them apples uh yes sir did
you consider the move Knight before in
this position
and you have this lovely Square on G3 so
I was not sure if you can analyze this
uh
I was ready to yes ready to sacrifice
The Exchange you you guessed you guessed
it right away so after Knight D3 what
was
um you you did it the wrong way I wanted
you to play Knight C2 so I could go Rook
E5 and sacrifice The Exchange that way
you went 93 you you made a zip when I
wanted you to make a zap maybe here you
have you will have to play rookie 3 but
I'm not sure that this was your original
intention then I will simply take on B2
and take on D4 right
yeah now I feel I haven't I haven't
achieved that point but I wanted it all
d2 is just so strange no I don't like it
either you're you're right uh if night
before
is and so that means I should okay I
apologize in that case so I'll start
with captures on D on D4 and then play
rookie one okay it takes D4 yes okay
this is uh possible yes a better
continuation well thank you very much
uh let's have a look because it puzzled
the computer itself by the way do we
have a name for our computer I don't
know you keep saying he I was expecting
you to say she suggests she wants to
play but you were saying he I hope that
our viewers has come up with a name
forever right yes for our silicon
creature we were reaching out yesterday
to the audience to jump in and make a
suggestion so let's say Rook seat and
now you can play 95 that's perfect now's
the moment now's the moment 95 right so
95.
Rook taxi five is a pawn no can I take
over the Rook
Rook takes sorry it doesn't want you can
do it be brave Almera yes I mean he
because that's the idea behind The Rook
sea they can play Rook C5 oh
for example I'm very surprised by this
movie those are the moves which usually
um Escape my vision during the game very
often you place your rook in an open
file but then uh well you're not
considering Rook C5 and then bringing
its a lateral move right later on but
this is a very nice defensive moves and
multi-purpose moves so after Rook C5 I
think black is fine here what's perfect
yeah
and by the way uh we love when our
audience involves themselves in the
conversation and tries to stump our
panel of experts how can they do it so
please send us your tweets using Karen's
cup or you can also send us your
questions and comments uh via twitch and
YouTube channels on Saint Louis chess
club Channel
wonderful and we don't want to lose
track of the super sharp game that I
have on my board currently this is the
game between Elizabeth
yeah where after Bishop G2 we didn't see
the inclusion of H6 and B4 rather we saw
Bishop B7 which I'm sorry let me just be
very clear here
to my mind that's a logic glitch
what I mean to say is you just played
Rook B8 precisely uh if you want to play
Bishop B7 Play Bishop B7 Bishop B7 maybe
you maybe in the future you will decide
whether B8 or C8 or gosh no it's d8
might be the the right square but if you
play Rook B8 and then play Bishop B7
kind of combined in two different ideas
that shouldn't that that shouldn't
necessarily cooperate with one another
but we did have Bishop B7 and Elizabeth
said well wait a minute aren't you
allowing me to play F5
forcing you to do something about this
Pawn on E6 E5 I'm surprised what Bishop
takes F6 was that necessary what if we
just moved the knights to B3 for now
right
from the black side until I play H6 I'm
always uncomfortable with the bishop on
G5 right so we could wait and let black
play H6 spend a Tempo and then take on
F6 I'm thinking that she's doing for
very specific specific reasons Bishop
takes F6 you don't want to take with the
bishop because then I've got yeah I've
got one of these uh standard night
sacrifices for three pawns and your king
might be stuck in the center you'll have
to recapture with the Knight right
and now where's my brilliant follow-up
to this
I thought she was about to play G5 but
I'm now beginning to ask Almira if the
night sacrifice actually works in this
position well it's on B5 yes uh oh oh
Mary you got a different game uh on your
screen sorry too uh force you to go back
and uh look at the game uh between
Elizabeth and good night for just a few
times that I've done the night sacrifice
it never worked I don't believe in it
anymore and that's he's saying that she
doesn't like the move Bishop takes F6
either well I agree with you Nancy
because that's why I was looking at this
position I was thinking were you forced
to give the the bishop straight away or
I I like actually to keep the bishop on
G5 because let's say after Knight B3 if
you finish your development let's say I
will make well some simple move I don't
let's say King B1 to illustrate my point
after age six I was thinking if age four
was is possible you know so that you
just keep the bishop there and black
simply cannot take because after H takes
D5 is H takes G5 you know you will be
facing a lot of mating threats so maybe
it was a little bit premature but Nazi
you were analyzing the sacrifice on B5
after F5 E5 immediately yes Bishop X6
Bishop F6 Bishop F6 and here yester
suggests Knight takes P5 okay let's say
Knight B5 and I don't think because
people believe me
you see the computer is already
preferring Black's position yes so we'll
take even though you're sacrificing a
piece minus one is not that bad okay yes
screen B6 let's say maybe 96 here King
E7 so normally when you sacrifice a
night on B5 then you have the F5 Square
so if I if I make a parallel in between
the openings especially like four nights
also you have this so how would you
continue here your Bishop is on G2 and
you desperately need it here exactly I
think uh yes the computer is right here
and have a look at the queen number six
Rook on V8 and you know I'm looking at
your pound on B2 good point what can you
do let's try Queen C4 yes because you're
a threatening a few things here so maybe
I can simply protect with Rook f8
actually behind you I just saw this line
by the engine instead of Rook Cafe there
is Bishop G5 check the resolution King
B1 Bishop D5 oh my God because I'm I'm
spectacular for the moment yes I'm
making more human moves like yes and
then Bishop D5 here
I would resign here
but that's not the position you want to
play so maybe there is a way for you to
oh well to improve after King E7 but
then no it's like you don't want to play
B4 here and then yes this position is
quite rather hopeless I would say so
maybe it was a bit harsh to take on B5
here
um but can you play Knight D5 here I was
just thinking in this position okay do
you have to be consistent you too
exactly for a purpose for the reasons
right you you took an F6 for a reason so
let's say if Bishop D5 then I can take e
takes D5 and then well my knife is no
longer in Priest and I have this lovely
C6 square and now I'm very enthusiastic
uh with the C6 Square so yeah it takes
F6 would probably be required then and I
think that yes there also maybe that's
uh at times you can even play 96 here
you know I'm wondering yeah let's say
castle castle here okay here of course
you would go Knight C6 and then I avoid
is much better choice yeah definitely
um
as just as we prepare ourselves to go to
a break Amir I just have a quick
question is Bishop B7 Theory because I
see the move Rook B8
and I don't understand why the rook and
B8 and the bishop on B7 went hand in
glove with one another well sometimes
you make
you make one move to provoke the move
that white don't want to play and then
you make another move this could be a
possible explanation but uh Bishop B7
was played in a few games okay so it's
still theory yes it's still Theory and
let me have a look at the results a lot
of draws actually it's a very strange
it's like when computer announces zeros
wow well thank you for that Almira and
just before we go on break first of all
let's remind everybody where we stand
after round one we have four leaders
this latest won their games yesterday
and crush and we had one draw so
technical have half points excellent and
as we do go on break we always check in
with our friends at Q Boutique and see
what specials they have well this is a
World Chess Hall of Fame athletic jacket
it's the newest edition from the World
Chess Hall of Fame and is not to be
missed the jacket is 95 polyester and
five percent spandex access features an
outstanding durable
press logo of the World Chess Hall of
Fame on the front available in men's and
women's styles do all your shopping at
cubic all your chess shopping at cute
Boutique St louis.com and we're going to
see you on the other side of our break
[Music]
hello everyone this is wgm a former US
Women's Champion Sabina fleisher I'm
very excited to be here in San Luis at
the Third Edition of the Karen's cup
I'll be taking over San Luis chess club
social media accounts so please if you
want to interact with me and see more
behind the scenes actions and videos of
the players be sure to follow San Luis
chess club social media accounts
the beauty in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out
q-boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our standings after round one we have
four co-leaders costume
they all won beautiful games yesterday
and we had one draw between Nana and
Anna zatomsky and in round two things
are certainly heating up as we were
taking on our break we came back and we
saw us inside to play this very shocking
move for my eyes night before in my
Spidey Sense immediately started
tingling you can't do that I'm gonna
take a pawn if Nana captures the first
move that caught my eye
um Nasi is that if you play Knight C2
intending that you will be able to
recapture not so fast not so fast just a
second let me remind you that your
Bishop is hanging you're welcome to
munch my Rook but if I take your Bishop
the Knight will be trapped and if you're
forced to capture here well you've just
lost a pawn so fix everything for what
right exactly so takes maybe a
bankruptcy too Bishop C2 okay so I'm
forced to move my queen right so let's
say queen uh to uh C1 I might have this
annoying move here Bishop E4
you're not cooperating you know I was
waiting I was waiting for you to play
Bishop D3 I was doing this sacrifice and
exchange in a very nice way Bishop E4
okay so that's Pawn number two
I take a pawn you can hear the Knight on
D3 afraid
oh I'm always afraid
but tell me what I should be afraid of
before we go what's 93 93 Queen C3
oh no don't play Knight D5 I really want
to but I can't
very very good uh let's just take a
quick look around the corner maybe uh
two of our top leaders Bishops of
opposite colors I don't know harika and
Alexandra should be evenish let's go to
um pardon me let me go to the arena
Crush game this is humpy versus Arena
crush this was the Queen's Gambit
accepted there was a trade and the
doubling of the pawns I don't know two
Bishops I feel black is okay definitely
very very much also White's completely
safe as well yeah yeah balanced position
finally a game we we're going to get to
as soon as we get back all the ball all
the pieces are on the board between
Bella and Anna that's uh a dynamic
symmetrical position a dynamic fighting
game going on and then this is the crazy
game
from that
um naidor yes where okay where is Black
going to put her Queen uh put her King
pardon me that is the big question
as we have Almera with a very very
special guest in studio very important
person
thank you yes sir I have Carl mayor with
me in the studio she is the executive
director of the U.S Chess Federation
welcome Carol I would like to ask you a
few questions and I just learned myself
actually that the U.S Chess Federation
has moved its headquarters to Saint
Louis so tell me more about this move
what are the reasons and what do you
like about the city sure U.S just
decided about a year and a half ago to
to make the move from its prior home in
Crossville Tennessee
for a variety of reasons first and
foremost you know St Louis is the chess
capital of the United States so we
wanted to be here to leverage a lot of
the activity that goes on here on our
our behalf
but it also became clear that over over
time crossfill had served us well but we
were having it a difficult time hiring
the kinds of staff and the skills we
needed in Crossville so our board voted
in December of 2022 or actually January
of 2022 to to make the move and that set
in motion a series of things finding
space and then of course selling the
building we owned in in Tennessee which
we sold last August
well I think you have a lot of new
programs going on and I've learned I've
also learned that you worked in a
variety of organizations which didn't
have anything to do with chess so you
started to serve the U.S chess in 2017
so please tell me about those programs
and the how how do you revolutionize U.S
chess oh wow yeah so revolutionize maybe
a strong word but so I was hired at a
time when U.S chess was going through a
transition the transition was because we
had been a
technically a 501c4 organization which
is a membership organization it's a it's
a federal tax status and during the
prior years we became a 501c3 which is a
charitable organization and in order to
maintain your charitable status much
like the St Louis chess club you have to
meet your mission and so I was hired to
do a handful of things one was make us
more like a charity while preserving our
traditional activities of being a
membership organization and serving our
members having a rating system and all
so what we did was we put together a
fundraising team we developed programs
and some of our programs have been
supported by the St Louis chess club
most most notably our our women's
program and all of those things have
started to flourish and grow and and we
were reaching many many more people
because we're not just limited to the
members that we serve and so it's been a
really exciting time well talking about
the members could you tell me what is
your membership base and what is the
percentage of men and women who play
chess in America sure so
um this has been an amazing year for us
uh during covid we lost almost 50
percent of our members and in May 2021
we our membership bottomed out and we
started gradually climbing back and in
February this year we hit a hundred
thousand members for the first time
which was a huge milestone for us
currently our membership is about 12 and
a half percent female which is a very
very small percentage
we're working with our women's program
to try to grow and retain more women in
chess and I think one of the really
interesting
data points if you will that that
we've uncovered is there is never parity
in membership at any age between men and
women in U.S chess or boys and girls and
so the the Gap is the smallest at age
five and it continues to widen
um All Through the Ages and that's
really a difficult challenge for us to
try to solve and through our women's
program and through other activities
like art support for Title One schools
we're just trying to bring more kids
into into the game of chess and you know
some of them will be female and and
we're just going to keep at it until we
we see more parity
uh thank you and those are very
important initiatives indeed uh would
you be so kind as to share with us what
are the most important upcoming events
so you I I think Junior seniors yes
championships yeah so um the St Louis
chess club again this year is hosting
the U.S junior U.S junior girls and
Senior Invitational events in July and
then in October the U.S championships
the
um Women's Championship as well will be
held in October and we always love being
here in St Louis they do an amazing job
with every event they run
thank you so much girl I wish I could
play one of those tournaments
and hope to see you soon very good thank
you Carol first of all congratulations
uh just one quick question before you go
um covet impacted everybody impacted
your member organization but for me one
of the most spectacular events I've ever
attended was the supernationals in
Nashville did you miss a supernationals
did the USCF miss the super Nationals we
did the the last supernationals was to
have been in May of 21 and as you know
things were still very uncertain and
some of our youngest players weren't
even eligible for vaccinations at that
point so we we had to cancel it but we
have one on tap for 2025 in Orlando
Florida so we're looking forward to that
and we expect it to be really really big
probably 6 500 or 7 000 players wow wow
well again congratulations thank you for
everything you do and especially to the
executive board as well for your
leadership
I attended the super Nationals
overwhelmed it's just so incredible very
natural there were I think 5500
coaches and parents A Galore it's it's
fantastic
um jumping right back into the games by
the way uh this move by it's inside of
the move night before you know like I
said my Spidey Sense was tingling like I
didn't think that that move was a good
choice
yeah we're gonna have to cancel her
membership uh Knight E5 was her choice
Bishop C2 Queen C1 Bishop E4 what's your
take on uh this this position it's hard
for me to figure out what's going on
with this artificial placement of the
pieces but I think does white have D3
right now d2's E3 let's take a look
because if I can finally move that D2
Pawn which has been bothering me
from the very start of play you might
say do to D3 uh putting the question so
if I take this is this is where you
wanted to go I guess that you felt was
it Rook D1 or rookie one Rook D1 Rook D1
uh I just pause here because I'm seeing
this maybe I don't know is this awkward
or what do you think
yeah and do you keep the pawn
what can I say I work so hard to win
upon him I wasn't anxious to return yeah
and that is uh a darn good move because
you're hitting the pawn on B7 but also
maybe you're just setting up a queen C4
yeah I yeah I I like white I mean this
is an actually uh working out so d2d3
right here why aren't you trying to take
the pawn what's wrong
I was just uncomfortable
with three
like not immediately though because I'll
take on day four I also don't like the
Rooks coming to see it okay and then
maybe you're a little bit uncomfortable
also at night to see too
wow white squares look particularly weak
right now so yeah well here though I I
find myself more attracted okay but now
here's the point you didn't want to
trade in the loud Rook C8 right yeah
okay intriguing all right I think that
only helps black
I think that exchange only helps blacks
yes uh bringing the Rook uh to
um
uh CA I just heard some update Vari is
telling us that in the game pets Mama
Zara yep I've got that's the crazy night
orph Bishop takes F6 uh let's jump over
to Miller Amir what's the story well
first of all I uh had a look at uh good
night's decision to take on uh F6 with
the pound you know I think it reminds us
a little bit of irina's game yesterday
but the structure is of course not the
same and why it has this possibility to
play H4 well well you still have the
pawn on G4 here so that was not the
games in irena's games so I I it's a
very suspicious move so uh Elizabeth
played Knight B3 which is a very natural
move in this position so Knight B6
because Knight D5 is coming and gunai
wanted to avoid
the streets let's say we're still
following uh one game here but Elizabeth
uh played let me have a look she played
here uh H4
and Rook C8 was played by black the
thing is what move can you possibly make
in this position how many more tempies
can you lose because you already played
Rook B8 Rook B8 Bishop B7 then Rook seed
once again and where are you going to
Castle of course you are not going to
Castle
uh short and you your king is stuck in
the center so computer thinks that here
it's still slightly better for white and
after Rook C8 he changes the evaluation
completely and it hesitates it's in
between 1.7 1.9 so but I think we should
offer a human perspective on this
position because it doesn't really
matter what computer thinks because you
have so many attacking possibilities
here and let's say even if I play a
prophylactic move King B1 and you will
do something like this which is very
natural in this position I have this
beautiful option once again the move
nice which you don't think immediately
off and then you protect the night on C3
so let's say if 93 you can take with
your rook and your Rook also can cut
into the attack too you can come back to
G3 and play G5 later yeah no I don't
like this position for black I feel that
White's space and just the fact that
Black's King still hesitating it doesn't
have a safe Square makes me feel
uncomfortable for yeah definitely why it
looks like they got everything they
wanted out of the position exactly and
the blackish is very passive doesn't
seem like they have enough counter play
[Music]
yeah questioning what are you going to
do I'd like to turn our attention to uh
humpy's game uh with Arena Karachi again
Arena wanted their tournament leaders
homepie the defending Champion needs a
win I would say after uh her her game
yesterday
a6a5 uh the last move I like this move
very much you want to stop the night
from coming to the C5 square a five uh
A5 A4 Rook A5 and Rook B5 even
potentially on Arenas agenda if we put a
few moves on the board and we just go
night here tonight here these Bishops of
opposite color positions I always felt
that black is actually very fine uh in
fact in this particular position center
is fantastic in Bingo to begin with the
King is fantastic secondly the half open
B file gives black Dynamic counter
chances and the only weakness the pawn
on A6 is easily defended by both King
and and Rook so I'm thinking black Irina
is going to say
I'm doing fine and she's doing very well
on the clock as well she has hour and
five minutes right humpy has 40 minutes
so irina's doing really well Bishop's of
opposite color we'll go to another one
two black pieces yes no issues at all uh
we'll go to another uh a very important
game as two of our tournament co-leaders
are battling in this round and we're
referring to Alex Zandra as well as
harika this is the Bishops of opposite
color almost from the opening it's kind
of like when zip right to these
positions and this position how would
you
evaluate this one the definitely like
Blackmore because the pawn on D6 feels
like it's more vulnerable than the pawn
on C5 also white Rooks
even the black Pawn on A4 it feels like
it's dominating the queen side
yeah it's like pressing yes pressing is
the yeah the perfect word for it and
yeah
probably it's still objectively equal
but I would much rather be black here
wow
okay
um I don't really have too much to
disagree with you about on the the
scores uh again I do see that the King
on E6 is going to you know keep the
pressure on the pawn and like you say
the spawn on A4 is just pressing white
you know put the pawn on A6 let me play
Rook A5 and the tables yeah exactly
that's exactly what a role reversal
there uh and uh a game uh that we didn't
pardon me get a chance to look at too
much yes
Bishop okay I'm not a fan I'm not a fan
of Bishop to D2 uh in these positions uh
so much of the
um the question of uh that is White's
Advantage severe or not uh is on the
pivotal F5 Square so in my view it's
really incumbent upon white to
immediately put a knight on the Square
F5 and let's go let's you know Knight H4
please positional question for you so
should white never play A4 here because
I'm slightly uncomfortable with black
having the opportunity to play A4 and
put more pressure on the queen side
um I'm I'm of the mind that actually I
like to see the move A4 and I think
that's what Bella's uh question point is
with the move Bishop to D2 I think she
would be welcoming the move A4 because
she'll have B4 and she wanted her Rooks
to be connected so anything like a b a b
and I'm back to my fun uh fun and games
with B4 and B5 so I think the move
Bishop D2 was designed to kind of like
coax the move A4 the reason I don't like
Bishop dd2 is because
the file the D file is the open files
still play Rook D1 and then put the
bishop back on c yeah so let's just put
some moves on the board not necessarily
a good move not necessarily a bad move
Queen C8 Bishop H3 let's just put and
now Bishop C1 very a rather standard uh
way of bringing the rook in and putting
things backwards
um okay a lot of chewing and throwing
going on over here Almira but how did
the engines evaluate uh the game between
Bella and Anna well I analyzed also a
couple of moves here what I wanted to
tell you today we have a lot of openings
that I play myself so I I had this
position a few times and very often I
play the the radio with knighters 3g3
which can give this type of position so
first of all you should be very careful
with the move A4 with white here because
you've certainly fixed the B5 square but
the square on B3 is way more important
so in order to do so you have to
exchange those Bishops if you would play
affiliador your Bishop would be on E2
and this would be a much better Square
that's why actually black takes uh
exchanges here on e4 and goes for this
position because black is claiming that
the bishop on G2 is much worse than on
E2
and they're probably right but computer
hesitated for a while here so he thought
that black was a bit better but now he
thinks that the position is about equal
so he even considers the move A4 here
but I would start with uh Rook D1 I like
this D5 Square so I want to prepare
those
the
one of the problems in this position
this what I wanted to underline is this
bishop on C1 right so you have and
especially there would be a very nice
opportunity if you could have played
Bishop G5 and take on F6 and then
install your knight on D5 but here you
will always have to think about the ways
of how to develop it and to connect your
Rooks
so for the moment the computer thinks
that it's equal and let's see what does
his can he thinks about B3 as well
because maybe he wants to to play at
Philadelphia style and to place the
bishop on B2 but uh
I don't know if I would try this move in
this position he likes your move yes sir
Queen save here okay
so like for the moment it's quite
balanced I would say thank you for that
mirror in the lifetime Head to Head uh
between uh these two players
very equal uh in in the game uh between
Elizabeth and gunay we do have uh a
declaration I want to say after the move
Rook CA King B1 what can black do I mean
at certain moment you have to make a
declaration what are you doing with your
king are you going to Castle short are
you going to leave your king in the
center castling long is not permitted
obviously
declaration we're leaving the king in
the center Rook G8 I like the move Rook
H3 but I I must say I mean I'm actually
more partial to Rook D3 why
because the Rook on the H file actually
might serve as well if I get in G5 any
captures in my Rook lands on H7 I'd
rather have my Rook on D3 than on D1
your thoughts uh I was just going to say
that black king I wouldn't be surprised
if it still ends up fake castled on
either side yeah it takes a walk whether
you're saying it takes a walk to C7 or
it takes a while to G7 somehow it
doesn't stay in the center but the move
Rook D3 asks a very pertinent question
what are you doing
I guess Blackness would do something
with the Knight either go Knight C4 or
A4 one of those options right okay yeah
another from C4 since Rook is on D3 it's
not threatening anything anymore earlier
there are some ideas with Knight C4
black could play Knight takes B2 or
Knight takes A3 right so Knight C4 for
example in this position as you just
described it would be threatening both
Knight A3 as well as Knight B2 and
probably forced Rook to D3 so yeah
prophylactic uh play Rook to D3 and now
maybe Knight A4 let's try that okay and
I I must say uh when Anatoly karpov
uh became world champion in 1975 that
was when Bobby Fischer refused as
Challenger there was this amazing
candidates match between karpov and
spassky and in that match the natural
player Boris baskey got outplayed by the
world junior champion and it's olly
karpoff and one of the things that
karpov did as white as he played this
beautiful beautiful game with this night
maneuver coming around once you've
doubled the pawns this night is either
going to go to
um uh B4 or C3 now in this particular
case I could imagine though The Rook is
actually more dangerous than the
defensive Rook I might be tempted just
to take it off just to eliminate the
possibility that you might be able to
attack so Knight A4 doubling the pawns
but Knight C4 doesn't doesn't appeal
either because I couldn't find them
right Knight C4 you might just encourage
me to to set up shop on the D5 Square
not easy for black to play this position
in the game Amira
uh actually I wanted to show you a very
beautiful tactical idea for example I
analyzed the move Knight A4 okay it
looks very natural as well as Knight C4
but I wanted to understand for example
why can't you play Knight D5 here since
the Knight left the B6 Square so I'm so
eager to take on D5 with my Rook right
but then computer immediately thinks
that black is better and he's telling me
that I should tell should take on G5
with the my pound which I would never do
and after Rook D5 you have that is
beautiful this beautiful move so let's
have a look at this position black is
completely winning and you know this is
not something which is coming up to your
mind immediately right so you have to
always to be aware of of beautiful
tactical ideas and which could turn the
tables in one move that's the cold
shower move Queen C3 you don't see the
move Queen C3
so it's on the board and it's too late I
tried here after Rook D3 I tried to move
uh King f8 but I was also wanted to
understand uh what would be the White's
plan after Rook D3 because uh and Knight
C4 because this is a more human move so
I tried to make this work because it
seems for me as a very natural
cancellation so you should say here yes
I will take on age seven and open the
position I think it's much better for
white but maybe the computer suggestion
here is a bit better he wants to play
Bishop F3 I think in order to prepare a
G5 so let's say you would make this move
so I will play G5 we'll take on G5 take
on G5 Bishop G5 Rook H7 and then you
have this powerful thread Bishop H5 nice
so maybe this could be well an organic
continuation of this game or as Nazi
said King f8
so what do you do here after king of
eight
G5 let's go so Bishop F3 I mean uh what
am I supposed to do open the position
yes we are opening up the position and
uh
it's it's very interesting when you
analyze to understand what could be the
course of the game right so you evaluate
the consequences of each move and that's
how you relate candidate moves so this
position actually computer thinks that
it's only slightly better for uh for
white and why this is essential the
Knight is still on B6 and I think that
now you can reroute it here
so maybe we should not be that harsh and
prepared G5 all right a little
preparation and by the way we again
would like to welcome you to join our
conversation how can our audience do
that you can send us tweets using
Karen's cup or if you're watching us on
YouTube or twitch uh also feel free to
send us questions comments at the Saint
Louis chess club Channel
indeed and we love to be stumped by your
questions and I just want to bring up
the game between
and Irina for a moment because we saw
this move A5 and I thought it was
important to play night here at night
here a different approach the night on
G3 is no great shakes either it's not
doing that much so Knight to E4 and A4
just kind of keeping this Knight a
little bit Frozen and the inclusion of
the move A4 to my mind is so important
for black because if
Arena can play Rook beef Rook A5 Rook B5
keep control of the C5 Square so you you
have to occupy it with a pawn she's
going to be doing just fine fine I think
she's doing more than fine I already
prefer black exactly I like the two
Bishops I like the fact that uh there
that there's counter play and by the way
don't forget this is actually a pretty
handsome uh Outpost in the middle of the
board that night on D5 will look pretty
good so Arena's doing quite well we
think take a look at Carson York Toronto
Valley game
um our leaders to leaders plain yep uh
Alexander just played F4
what do you think of this move
oops sorry I'm just support form yep
sorry I just clicking F4
um
I'm not quite sure I I'm uh because I
think opening a position might help
black people exactly uh you always have
to say who benefits after for example
King E6 who benefits best uh by having
an open f file and I would say it's
black black is ready to play Rook f8
check and be the first to control so
but I think that's already a symptom
that
Alexandra's feeling a little
uncomfortable about her position and the
move F4 is kind of designed maybe to
simplify the position a little bit but
as she doing more harm than good with
this move F4 and uh
yeah I'm warming up uh to uh to a
Black's position but we do have our
tweet that we've been calling for what
do you have for us nothing let's take a
look the question is Yasser mentions
mihail tal all the time what is your
favorite
story okay first of all too many to
choose from don't even go there we will
be how long you got we got hours to
spare
um one of my actually uh really really
really favorite stories was I had
visited the Soviet Union I was the coach
for a James Tarzan and Edmar Madness and
it was the interzonal it was a
tournament held in Riga
the hometown of Michael tall and it was
one of these tournaments the last I
don't know six weeks it's a single round
robin 20 players with all kinds of free
days and adjournment days so it goes all
the time tall had arguably the greatest
success of his career I mean it was just
unbelievable what happened I mean he won
like every game he was better he won and
every game he was worse he drew it was
just like it was one of those events and
he won the tournament by some massive
score like really it was a four-point
gap between persons yeah it was really
that
so in there at the closing ceremony in
his hometown
and the poor dude he's called to the
stage and the winner of the best the
most brilliant game Michael Thomas week
it's like two bouquets of roses and he
goes and he sits down and he puts them
on his seat and then the winner the
basketball game right so there's Michael
Bell I mean by the time he'd gone back
and forth like five times
he had no place to sit uh it was one of
those you have to be there to believe it
type of thing and then the other one
that really just clicks with me I think
it's so funny he was the only guy that
could do this it was a Montpelier it was
the candidates tournament I was one of
the players and we're all sitting on a
stage very nice seating big tables in
front of us but we all have chess boards
in front of us so there's eight
candidates with the chess board on each
of our tables in front of us and we have
to go up in the drawing of lots so
everybody goes up takes their number
Michael talls is called please Misha
come and draw your number so you pull
out your seat you go to draw the number
on the way back Michael Tall doesn't go
around the table he stays in front of
the table and he makes a move on each of
them
both days to all look at it the audience
loved it and applauded him for making
the moves as as if he's in a
simultaneous
all of us having dinner at the opening
ceremony looked at each other Boris
baskey laiosh portish Victor korchnoy
and said he was the only one who could
have done that without offending anybody
like he was so well beloved if any one
of us had done that we would have been
labeled arrogant and everybody would
have been angry but this year was
special
and just to remind everyone he of course
won the World Championship in 1960 force
of nature in his book uh Michael Tall
versus Michael vodvinick 1960 is
absolutely one of my favorite favorite
chess books of all time I've read it
about 10 different times in my career
from being a class player to an expert
to a Master to International Master to a
grand master and each time I thought I
was reading it for the first time I
think it's time for me to reread it
again it's a great great book Amira what
game is caught your eye thank you for
the question by the way well I first of
all before I wanted to mention that I
was so happy that you talked about Paul
Karis one of my favorite players and now
Michael tile because he he had such an
original mind such a unique vision of
situations and that's transpired even in
the everyday life so I also was thinking
about the decisive games and about those
matches talbotwini but Phoenix tell they
had so many decisive games in those
matches that nowadays it would seem
completely surreal
so
sorry yes
I was looking at this position and I
wanted to explain
that they move F4 which Alexander just
played was
um quite understandable because what is
Black's idea of course I want to put my
king on E6 and to win this pound somehow
with the Rook C6 Rook E6 double my Rooks
so I was wondering and it is quite human
of course you don't need to take here
and then well you will improve my Bishop
positions although this is not the end
of all your troubles but after King is
six I was thinking maybe uh Alexandra
was
intention looking at this possibility
you know so but did it happen on the
board it did I saw that your your game
got updated with the move G7 G6 okay yes
because I was actually trying to
understand her training well the way she
thinks about the position so I was
absolutely right after King is sick she
played G4 and harika well because she
wants to play F5 of course let's say I
will make a move which is not really
very useful maybe she wants to play F5
and then King F7 but even here
um the computer thinks that the black's
position is much better because you have
this powerful bishop and at some point I
will play H5 let's say you will play H3
I can play H5 and bring my Rook to the H
file and I think that white is in Dire
Straits already here so you have to be
very careful I think that her opening
strategy backfired
and she's going to be fighting for a
draw for a very long time here
especially after G6
so let's see what can we consider here
maybe take on E5
well you don't want to take 25 with the
king so F take C5 and to exploit those
black squares maybe bring the king to G3
and but still Rook f8 so what do you
think maybe after
um take only five maybe I can play
Bishop G5 and put my Bishop on E7 is
this a valid the sound option for you
well for me the bishop on E7 is pretty
but actually it's rather defensive too
like Rook f8 check right at least on the
E3 Square you were press pressuring the
C5 Pawn Yeah here not so sure the bishop
belongs that's a little bit annoying
because black will not be able to double
on a file well okay so I'll play Rook F3
okay right just uh let me trade one Rook
so that the pawn on D6 is a little bit
more vulnerable right it just feels like
black is having the fun that's for sure
yes yeah yeah black is the one having
the white pawns on D6 especially pushed
too far so now you know you can compare
the Kings with one another for a moment
the King on E1 versus the King on the E6
who who's more useful yeah I'd like to
just turn our attention for a moment to
the game of Elizabeth uh and gunay
because uh we did see Bishop F3 by
Elizabeth and with the move H6 black is
rather shutting down the whole concept
of uh G5 and I love these types of
fights what I will call a strategical
battle and whether whenever I'm in these
strategies magical battles I talk to my
pieces how you doing how are you doing
how are you doing so I kind of go across
the board and everybody's happy and the
one piece when I look at White's
position that I don't like that piece
would be and I don't B3 bro the Knight
on B3 absolutely what is the night on B3
doing it's not going to A5 it's not
going to C5 it's not going to D4
if the night was on B4
then I'd be transferring the D file and
it's uh action action so I'm looking at
night to see one with the idea Knight to
A2 to B2 it's a long-winded variation
but then the question is well what is
black going to do blacks pieces are more
or less
optimal I mean I don't know how you're
going to approve your pieces but if I
can put my knight on B4 put this Rook on
D1 cement my control over the D5 Square
I think it's play on one goal and uh
since so we agree that night on B3 is
the worst piece right would you consider
exchanging that night for Black's best
which I think is the night on C4 I would
so 92 is also an option absolutely
absolutely I would indeed I would say
what's my opponent's best piece the
Knight on C4 Knight D2 I mean if you
want to go there absolutely why
[Laughter]
your take on the position
well as much as I wants to disagree with
you yesterday you know both please
that's right do your best I like the
move 92 that was the first move that I
wanted to analyze because uh for me it's
very natural but for example I play
swishnikov with black for me I played it
for many years and I wanted to show you
that after Knight C1 I think if there
was one useful idea that you've learned
because there are always a night day two
night before in this fashion you have to
prepare A5 so let's say after Queen B6 I
think that this is a very interesting
continuation and your nights are stuck
there so you will have to play Knight D5
here anyway right so but I'm not sure
that this is the um the right moment to
do so so because after Bishop D5 you
still well cannot take with the Rook
because then I will continue with my
swishnikov planner will play before and
I think that you're fine here with work
I see so that's why I like the move
Knight D2 better here get rid of the
night yes get rid of the night and but
still you cannot take I think because
after Knight the two queen D2 and you
well you have quite an advantage here of
course you want to take the power to
grab this one so maybe you will have to
play Rook h8 here and
um
you've lost so much time so after Knight
D2 I think that you just have to leave
the night there and maybe to make a
useful move something like I don't know
king f8 or queen A5 whatever
you like and then to take like this we
take C4
so what do you think about this position
hmm I'm not I don't know if I if if
opening up the B file was a good a good
idea because this I would be happy with
is white I would think that after for
example Queen D2 and the position you
have on my hand Almera is better for
white I'm ready to go Knight D5 and
occupy the square but that's why you
need to take on C4 right with a pound
yes well the B file and then okay you'll
have to go back
sometimes in this position you play Rook
King A1 and you defend yourself in this
way so yeah if you will double on on the
B file so it's it's not that dangerous
but after Rook D1 I was thinking how
many times black played rugby eight Rook
seat rugby again because you need to
adapt yourself to a completely new
situation but the computer thinks that's
uh that white is still much better here
after King E2 your king is very safe
here
right thank you for that uh Mira I just
want to turn our attention to the game
of Nana and
um
gotta get that uh guess what that moved
d2d3 the move that uh you wanted to get
rid of the deep Pawn on D2 now and I
agreed with you takes Bishop E2 Rook D2
and you know as a player of the Catalan
persuasion you're going to really
appreciate this beautiful diagonal I'm
going to take this Pawn I'm winning the
pawn and just compare the harmony of the
pieces for a moment this bishop is about
to work this bishop is about the knights
are jumping into the center and uh well
it is looking very very good and if you
and another move also
A3 uh kick the Knight out of Dodge and
then take on D4 either way I'm I'm
thinking white everything's oh actually
94 is an issue I was going to say I
apologize yeah I better play A3 as a
prelim to taking on D4 when the Knight
goes back to D5 I don't think you want
to go to C6 now I've got banana right
away she did yes okay so she does invite
so 94 94. yeah but is it so bad let's
say I just go back what do you want
indeed
you want are you gonna come back Bishop
B2 I don't think so okay one right right
no I think that this is a really nice
Advantage for uh Nana as we uh just
review our standings after the first day
of play and we'll prepare ourselves for
a break once again we have a four-way
time we're a four-way tie between uh
Costa New York Toronto Valley mamasada
and crush and uh two players have half a
point like Nita and satonski and we'll
see you on the other side of the break
for more round two action
thank you
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
in Forest Park
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our standings after round one we have
four weight high cost a new Toronto
Valley Mama Zara and crash all with one
point and Nana and Anna have half a
point after a draw yesterday absolutely
and in that game of Nana I've got to
tell you I mean I am just adoring
White's position everything about
White's position that I find incredibly
appealing this night on E5 beautifully
centralized supported by the bishop on
the long diagonal this night about to go
to the F5 Square uh hitting the bishop a
Tempo Against The Rook the bishop on G2
whereas the discordinate bishop on A6
the pass of Bishop on E7 no redeeming
future earlier today I was like do you
like tufian carrot Bishops well now I
well I'm glad you caught up yeah you bet
Nasi everything to like about this
position let's Jump Around the Horn a
moment uh this game I actually wanted to
save that was the game of farika I'm
gonna I'm gonna bring bring bring back
that game if you will I like the game uh
also of humpy our defending champion and
Arena I was mentioning that you know the
double pawns well double pawns are nasty
I don't like double pawns except in
those situations where in this case the
half open B file is giving black great
counter play arena is doing very well to
Rook C2 I think Arena
that's exactly the way I feel about this
position
um continuing uh the game between
um Bella and Anna took a Twist right
here I was thinking that White's
intention was to play with the
ambitiously one and or uh
no Bella jumped to the D5 Square changed
the pawn structure immediately uh change
the whole position really total
character of the position and now uh we
have to position after Queen A5 Knight
D7 Knight H4 on the board I can
understand what Bella is attracted to
here if we could sneak the bishop let's
let's let's let's say Bishop H7 shall we
if we sneak our Bishop to well you know
uh it starts to get a little bit uncomfy
uh suddenly I suppose uh honestly
welcome to exchange and playing Knight
P6 that's exactly what I was thinking
that uh Anna might have to part with the
two Bishops something along
like this and allow night takes F5 by
the way some crackling noises remarkably
it started to hail here in St Louis when
we had this very very sunny weather
coming into studio
um continues have buenos and I I hope
they can't hear it because it can be
quite disturbing absolutely I remember I
was playing in a U.S Championship
Gregory guy danov and I were at the at
the chess club in the St Louis chess
club at Scholastic Center and we were
playing underneath a skylight uh glass
window if you will and it started to
hail no no no no no like let me uh
explain that further it really was
coming down we had to stop the clocks
and just pause the game because the hail
was so loud we looked across the table
at each other Gregory and I did and we
just started laughing we could believe
how much noise uh the hail can make
against the glass window same for us
right now but I'm again hoping that they
have more it sounds good
the double glass windows and things like
that nature and then of course we have
uh the game of Elizabeth she did play
the she she liked your idea there 92 uh
we're talking about the strategy and the
fact that you know when you're in those
strategical positions look at what were
your opponent's best piece is the night
on C4 your worst piece how do you
improve Knight D2 let's trade off your
best boots
Knight went back to B6 we would like
at some point to threaten at least the
move Knight D5 don't want to lose the C2
pawn and that's why we understand the
move Rook C1 by Elizabeth she's prepping
the move Knight D5 nice nice I like
White's position because I think black
is still stuck where's she going to put
a king I really don't like Black's
lastmo which was H5 oh I'm sorry I'm not
up to date on the board he just played
um that's why I have a G5 which we
wanted to do earlier yes but now we can
actually grab the pawn on H5 uh you mean
after trade right trade I'm assuming
Rook take so we're just going for the
straight trades yeah because now after
the GNH files are open black king is
definitely a lot weaker than it was
before and the bishop is already there
but
now
you asked me can we
can I take the ball like I just want to
take yeah you you you've got double
death pawns you enjoy your double F
pawns I've got my double I'll enjoy my
Double H one maybe in this case moves of
H5 and if I can get your Rook to go to
h8 for whatever reason I guess Bishop f8
would be ah Bishop f8 okay trying to
block it from H6 gotcha and may I be so
cruel Knight to D5 I'm assuming you take
with the Knight
yes okay I'm assuming it takes so my
dream is twofold I want to play Rook C3
and 94. I don't like the Knight coming
to before I love it it depends on your
perspective right
it's all about perspective I like the
night on e4 you mean for what I do yes
yes so I'm not a big fan of the move H5
but I wanted to go to the game of harika
for just a moment and invite Almera to
come in because I really like this move
uh we were talking about
Alexandra's move Bishop H6 I'll mirror
on the break and we were saying what a
beautiful way of Defending
uh the pawn on D6 tactically and tell
our viewers what we were looking at uh
yes first of all I like this move a lot
and I think that we missed it in our
calculation Bishop H6 you take away the
f8 square so Rook f8 check is no longer
possible but I dismissed this move in my
analysis because I didn't check it with
the computer so I said okay but after
Rook C6 you simply lose a pound here
Alexandra played Rook 83 but computer
had a very interesting suggestion here
so he suggests Rook E2 here and so
Beauty yes if you take Rook D6 here then
simply Bishop F4 and you get this pound
back
and so
this was another way to defend the spawn
so after Rook E2
what happens then if you take
King D6 and you protect for the moment
of the balance and you're getting away
with it so the computer attacks the
phone E5 from G7 Square now nice so you
can protect it in this way but then you
can take on A4 and the position is about
equal wow and Rook on A3 to E3 because
I'd really like to recap you want to
recapture this one okay let's try sorry
this was the lines yeah
like give me that guy
rookie 3 is also possible but I think he
simply gives it up in this he gives it
back okay he gives it back but we have
in the game though isn't that to Black's
Advantage because White's Rooks don't
make a great impression on the they're
piled up on the D file which is closed
yes the computer didn't like the move
Rook ag3 because this is sort of a
passive defense yes and he as we've saw
yesterday in the games between uh John
said the Malik and Arena crash he is
always looking for a surprise and an
active defense as you remember C4 and B4
so bringing the bishop to the long
diagonal now I know by the way in
Russian it's also a big diagonal it's
it's very strange you know how those
things work in different languages so he
here he thinks that uh black is a bit
more has a bit more than in the previous
variation so maybe I should attack the
pawn on C4 so you will have to go back
Rook C3 because I think that B3
shouldn't be played in this position
because you can simply take take and
then it will be a long-term long-term
weakness so I can play rookie one let's
say you will move your king somewhere
and attack the pawn from here and it's
completely lost so
this is very very nice for black yes so
you shouldn't play B3 you should always
keep your pieces here
so after Rook C3 then maybe you can
improve your Bishop by playing Rook C6
and bring your second Rook to the B file
so
okay still a bit better for black and
much easier to play much easier to play
indeed and nasia I gotta tell you I'm
looking at this game of Nana and my
spidey sense is tingling I mean uh you
don't have to be an attacker to take a
look at this position you know imagine
that you had this as white yourself
you're feeling really really good what
goes through your mind how do you
approach White's attack I think my
problem here would be that I have too
many good choices
that's that's seriously a problem it
really is I've learned to go with the
most practical approach right so I
really like A3 move okay to drive the
Knight backwards A3 yeah it's between A3
and Knight of five right so if I have a
lot of time I will calculate and figure
out which one's best but it's not I'm
going with A3 so I'm not even sure where
I'm supposed to go with this night I
mean it feels terrible but okay if I do
go back to C6 I can go Knight F5 right
away right Knight F5 so what am I
supposed to do Rook here uh and now I
just need to find a tactic because this
has to be something exactly whether you
whether you do something as
unimaginative as this this is just oh
like you know it's painful to my eyes I
have a nice tactic for you you please
amera Jump Right In a queen B6 was the
last move and Nana is really enjoying
her position please I love the way and
as he explains how she chooses the move
the candidate moves in this position so
A3 and Knight F5 are the best moves
according to the computer but first of
all look at the valuation not that they
move so it's completely lost yes for
black and uh what I like after A3 Knight
C6 that you can play Knight F5 Rook E8
and here is your tactics you can take on
G7
ouch yes uh King G7 then Knight D7
because of course the night is pinned
you're attacking the queen so there's
not much that you can do here you know
what what can you try let's say yes you
you move the queen somewhere Queen C7 so
after Knight F6 unfortunately you cannot
take back because you have Queen G4
check
and this position is completely hopeless
so apparently checkmate
not only is it hopeless but uh yeah so
that's that's a very
um beautiful idea so Knight D7 Knight G7
and I think so 97 King G7 97 there is
not much that you can do because the
computer suggests Rock City you
understand this you know yeah we're not
going to to make this move on the board
so right uh I think white is winning in
about two or three moves here right a
multiplicity for me when I look at this
position as wide
um I see the position and I say I'm
really really really happy that your
night is on B4 in fact I'd be really
happy if your knight was on A5 like just
a way from the action so I find myself
drawn to the move Knight F5 at once move
like rookie eight and then I start to
think wow
non-diagonal
let's let's you know those checkmating
patterns that we all learn as kids you
know like the night can go to age six
and they can go out to G7 I like what
Almera was saying there about the move
Knight to D7 97 or before or even now
right just like go ahead take take my
night you know like you know you just
look at this position you just say
everything everything is in White's
favor but at the end of the day your
night's still way
sorry the reason I like the A3 is
because after Knight C6 I know that for
sure
great position no matter what even if I
don't see media Checkmate I have a great
position exactly and there's no counter
play whatsoever exactly so it's more
practical approach but I think you're
right Knight F5 is more precise yeah
just to have that uh the the those
attacking motifs of 97 Knight G4 boy oh
boy uh I mean the spirit of Michael Tall
enthuses me here with Knight F5 but
Almera uh what do you I mean what do you
think zensai is feeling at this moment
as she knows she's on the back foot and
she's facing
she's facing a a zero two start
well uh yes her position is completely
lost for example I tried Knight F5 Queen
E6 but you can even play Bishop H3 here
oh dear oh dear so the attack I think
that uh first of all
um uh her State well psychologically you
need to explain the situation she lost
with white so she
the advice I was always given by my
coaches that you well the Knight of
course should bring you some advice but
you need to try to play solidly not to
take any risks and try to make a draw
you know because of course in this
tournament you cannot offer a draw but
you you simply have to play a game of
chess against a very strong opponent
right and I think that uh
um Nana's opening Choice was uh very um
tricky because it does not allow you to
have a structure easy to play and that's
what happens you know when your opponent
doesn't have the patience and she as
usual Asians I went to one of the most
concrete lines she took the pound and
that backfired completely and indeed
talk about grabbing the bowl by the
horns here Elizabeth
she loved your G5 move and played it but
with a very different idea her idea was
that after G5 and we've got to take
because I really don't want to see the
move G6 land on the board that looks
just too ugly G6 and Bishop takes a try
you have to take Bishop takes so her
idea was go ahead take a pawn now F6 and
the open f file Rook F3 Queen F2 uh yeah
can also come to F1 precisely a land on
F7 well gunay said no no no I'm not
going to take on H4 and allow you that
much fun instead I'll play Bishop F6 and
she's trying to hold on for dear life
here uh Elizabeth definitely in the
driver's seat as Black's King is getting
caught in the center so would you take
on G5 now
after Bishop F6 I'm still attempted by
Knight D5 okay I'm still tempted by 90.
you just want to get the Knight on e4s I
really want to get by the way we had uh
made a shout out to our audience to tell
us what we should call the beasts you
know the engines and while we got a lot
of answers there was a couple there that
Sabina during our break had shared one I
like well it remind me the the one about
the deep blue that was pretty good yeah
that was my favorite not so deep blue
for the moment this is my favorite
because a lot of answers but I think we
are looking for maybe for a shorter one
that we could use every day but not so
deep blue is quite a funny one so right
something also a play on the Stanley
Kubrick Space Odyssey Hal 50. not not
the hell 2000 Hal 50 and somebody Adam
and Eve recommended Eve well we had a
couple of answers uh it was Bobby Bobby
it was Bobby I think as long as we don't
get a mysterious answer like 42 yes
and we've got some YouTubers as well
here we go here we go uh is this a
question we'll figure out okay
it could be named ponger wow wow okay
for three very obvious reasons Judith
Judith might be better right rolls off
the tongue nicely and arguably the best
female player ever
as long as she's okay with it one small
problem is the chief Arbiter is Judith
all right right so you know I don't know
I mean it's tough Elmira weigh in on
that you like Judith you like coming in
and saying Judith how we doing
we're actually we're born at the same
year so I was growing up you know well
watching juices always this is our chief
Arbiter Judith and well she'll be
honored I hope to know then you arrange
the doesn't mind but I've seen a few of
their proposals recently and that's
maybe wonder you have Wonder Woman but
they came up with blunder woman so you
know there's someone who has this
superpower and can avoid all the
blunders so I hope that they will allow
us to borrow this name for for a little
bit how about from the Greek mythology
Hera Harry is a nice one yes wisdom
powerful
yeah maybe a Tina as well I was thinking
about Hydra but you know this the image
is way too violent right I hate the
three-headed monster five-headed monster
but we have I think we have how many
days we have left yes we still have uh
you want us to remind you of the
schedule
okay we got seven more rounds we've gone
in for two now okay let's jump back
because okay Elizabeth is looking at you
know she's feeling good she's like okay
I got the initiative how do I follow up
uh take us through what you imagined her
thoughts are right here first of all I'm
not sure she's feeling good because
Almira told us she again woke up at 5am
this morning
she wakes up and she texts you in the
morning like are you awake right
so she's still jet lagged and she's
recovering from yesterday's very long
tough game she had right and yes they
lost the difficult ending position right
now is looking good but it's not that
simple that she can just play anything
and win like Nana's position right so
she still has a long fight ahead and if
our hair I'll probably take on G5 that
looks very natural to me I don't want to
give up the pawn on H4 okay and then I
like your idea of 95. okay so my take on
the position first of all is very very
simple
I Love Bug House
so I would say give me a Pawn
on E6 and I would picture myself well
how beautiful is my position breaking
down the position I see two things two
things that I'm really attracted to and
I would I would try my best to calculate
as deeply as possible to move 95. the
second thing is I see the pawn on G5 I
agree with you that H takes G4 but I
also see the possibility of the pin on
the G file so I start to think
here it comes can I win a pawn can I
play the move Rook uh G1 and can I play
the move Rook G3 if I could play H takes
G4 well H takes you I mean yes sir in
your games how often do you ask yourself
can I win a pawn
well it's funny that you should say that
because Alex you're milinski was telling
me he was writing his Masterpiece his
Opus there where he said you know yeah
sir I think I spent like 98 of My Life
as a professional asking what's what's
the pawn count
Alex you and I
and authors yeah
asking ourselves that question a lot so
but but take me through your thought
processes if you took and uh grenade uh
recapture Brook takes G5 what's your
following so let's go with oh am I
losing I'm not losing a point 95. okay
and by the way do we have moves she
heard your idea of just going for the
pawn yeah I mean Elizabeth you're
winning my heart just a second night D5
okay oh boy oh boy oh boy so deep
breaths here
I like that here looks on G5 Bishop on
F6 I know I mean it's like it's it's
right and even the desirable Rook takes
Bishop G4 is not a lot of fun either
Knight D7 trying to
94. 94 anyway yeah
oh boy oh boy
I mean it has to be bad I know I know I
mean I have Bishop G4 I have Rook G1
Queen G4 Rook F1 they all look good they
all look good look if one is a blunder
but okay uh I'm just I'm doing my best
to hold on I'm dreaming that I'll be
able to meet certain moves with Rook F4
and stuff we were holding here for the
moment because I didn't say how to win
but let's jump into what was played in
the game which again I find this move
personally very attractive and it's one
of those moves that I seek to put
pressure on my opponent right so that
I'm sitting there saying what would make
my opponent the most uncomfortable if I
play a move like hg5 uh it captures
they're always looking at captures first
because that's what we do we're chess
players what happens if I take so when I
play a move that's not a capture it's
sort of like maybe you haven't been
studying that move maybe I'm catching
you a little bit off guard so Rook G1
puts the pressure and Almira Jump Right
In uh how did the engines like
Elizabeth's choice
Elizabeth it's almost like Sophie's
Choice you know
sounds very philosophical actually the
computer like this move but he also
likes um Nazi's proposal you know to uh
yes because this idea of
um taking on G5 and uh Rook takes G5 and
Knight D5 is uh is a very strong
continuation here as you can see it's a
plus 2.8 yes because you will you cannot
really take on D5 because this Knight
book let's check it let's try Mr tactic
yes okay let's try something like this I
tried Knight D7 or yeah go ahead I just
wanted to sure we have to continue in a
very logical way so you simply go Knight
E4 here so you will try to to save
your rook and okay now you have to bring
a few pieces into play so the computer
is hesitating but it's still plus plus
five
yes so maybe Rook one series three yes
I don't know Queen D7 he wants to
exchange this Rook wow yes 98.
and now he continues with C4 I like this
move as well because you open another
file yes and uh you are playing on both
flanks because you cannot you will not
be able to defend everything so after C4
I think that uh the black's position is
not defendable well the thing about C4
that you really like it's sort of like
you come under the show afterwards and
you go well I played Rook C1 you know I
was dreaming I was going to play C4 one
day and it turned out to to be that way
so Rook G1 maybe not as powerful as H
takes G5 but not bad either right I'm
here yes but it's very human once again
and I wanted to understand so what was
White's idea for example if you make a
very natural move like King E7 you want
to connect your Rooks but here there
this is Elizabeth's idea because you you
have the in every variation you have
Bishop F7 so if you take on F7 then uh
Queen H5 oh take on F7 yeah
Queen H5 and white is completely winning
because right like the black skin is
exposed so
I think that Black's best option here is
to play G4
without yes of course so I just I
illustrate why it's idea so you have
simply to give up the spawn right and
but still you can take it and continue
the attack or maybe try something else
like Bishop G4 yes is a is a very
um simple way of capturing the pawn but
the com
by the way we do have the move King E7
on the board oh G4 you see it's very
human that's why that was the first move
I I yes I was analyzing but it's losing
uh by force show us how King E7 loses by
force that's a position on the board yes
once again we simply take on G5 so it's
no matter if it's well I showed you Rook
G5 but let's say Bishop G5 you still
take Bishop F7 yeah well one more look
Rook takes G5 Rook takes G5 Bishop takes
G5 Bishop takes F7 can I take on D2 yes
of course then you take with the queen
and now I take the bishop and that's why
this line is very dangerous the computer
continues like this and I'm just crying
no no but you have to uh analyze it till
the very end because it's far from being
obvious but unfortunately now The Rook
came into play you attack the the Knight
on B6 right and well the maiden threat
you you have pretty obvious a lot of
mating threads so I don't like and the
queen is also could be lost at some
point after Hurricane but you're
absolutely right you have to analyze
this variation till the very end
computers are ruthless of course but
this is why it's main idea I think that
Elizabeth will find and she has taken on
G5 hg5 Rook G5 on the board were
expecting Rook takes G5 and a very fine
Bishop sacrifice Bishop takes F7 is she
gonna find it
I think she already says it that's why
she
why ships HG but now she's double
checking fabulous
a nice vicious sacrifice coming up this
is uh a delicate yeah a delicate uh uh
move okay uh for Elizabeth yes it's a
very elegant solution like in
mathematics yes Bishop is 70. she's done
let's have a look we have it uh in uh
what I I imagine she will take her time
here to make sure it works because even
if she doesn't play Bishop F7 I'm sure
she has a lot of good moves here that
still keep a huge Advantage for white so
she wouldn't want to
right but I think the key here is that
move Queen H6 Bishop F7 King F7 is easy
that's just a check give me the bishop
that's nothing to calculate this is
where we just want to make sure that
everything uh Works uh nicely Bishop
takes Queen takes King takes you might
get uh sidetracked Rook takes D6 might
not be it also looks good it does look
good I mean but maybe Rook takes D6 Rook
h8 but this is where you find if you
find Queen H3 intending moves like Queen
E6 check as well as G3 as well as Rook
takes D6 you find Queen H6 it's done you
can close the book and how do they match
up
they had 10 games and Elizabeth has a
huge lead five wins one loss and
Fortress Guna is asking why did you
invite Elizabeth to the Karen's cup
and let's just see after round one that
very very decisive round uh update this
on the ratings the live ratings actually
all right so after round one and we can
see because question you'll beat conero
she's getting in about six points and
hump is losing six points uh hierikas
plus 4.5 Nana lost a little bit with the
draw Jean Saya has a big minus right and
um yeah well I have to say in the
amongst the uh men uh especially you
hear Magnus Carlson like Magnus what are
your goals he says I want to be 2900.
you talk to Wesley cell Wesley what's
your call I want to be invited the
grantchester I want my high rating is
that also true if the ladies game that
they focus on that because of Olympics
for invitations is it as it's as big a
deal for the ladies even here for the
Karen's cup invitations are mostly by
the rating exactly
relationships that's why I don't
necessarily play before the Invitational
rating in the fear of if I lose rating I
will not get invited right right you
feel
you you feel like you especially if
you're on the bubble you don't want to
and who you found by the way she Remains
the highest but we're waiting for the
Women's World Championship Match uh
coming up right Elmira uh yes and it
will feature two Chinese players June
June the Iranian champion and later she
just won the candidates this year and
she impressed me a lot I was doing
commentary during the candidates in
Monaco and the depths of her analysis
and the opening preparation is
it surprised me so I think she is
divorce the opponent and I think she she
has a higher rating right now than juven
June so she didn't play for a while so
even a favorite yes she might be a
favorite yes but what I was thinking you
were talking about while you were
talking about ratings I think it's also
important that you can make history
there were only a few women who crossed
the 2600 barrier for example Hamby
Conair is one of those players I think
her big rating was 26 23. so this might
be a very interesting objective in their
career
well for me though uh the the ratings
and the rating of inflation for me a
very very very strong lady player was
garbrandesh Philly
and I remember very vividly I was a
young man trying to earn my spurs get my
Grandmaster norms and moon Pine and this
was an amazingly powerful tournament
that was hosted here in in a United
States Lone Pine California came into
this all males field
top top top players won the tournament
nice right like won the tournament and
she wasn't even considered a top 100
rated player but she won the tournament
and probably at the end of that
tournament had one of the live ratings
that you would say crossed the 2600
barrier but nobody was 2600 those days
except for Anatoly karpov so it's
interesting how the ratings have changed
uh the game in the modern uh era I just
wanted to go to the game of Spanish
really because she was five-time women's
world champion from Georgia right where
I was growing up and when I was seven
years old she gave a simul and I played
my carocon only opening I knew at the
time and she was so impressed that I
knew the opening right around move 15
she offered me a drop that's the best
day of my entire childhood right oh you
were a hero in the household and that
also taught me that whenever I give
sandals now when the little kids are
doing well and playing well I always
offer a draw nice nice nice nice very
nice I wanted to turn the game uh our
attention to the game between Bella and
Anna because we're going to have a
serious imbalance that occurred just
catching up with the players on a did
play the move Knight F6 offering the two
Bishops Queen B5 Bishop B6 trade trades
Bishop E3 to defuse the attack on the F2
pawn bishop takes Rook takes an E4
gift Meet The Pawn on C4
C4 Knight G4 Rook E2 and I just saw
Knight H2 on the board Bingo Bongo
Knight takes H2 well uh guess what uh
that that's a wake-up call right there
Knight takes H2 Queen H5 check if we
take can we take on e4 it's
I think I have Rook a to E1 Knight takes
eight uh okay just a second Rook on A1
to E1 defends the rook and attack now
attacks nh2 uh pause pause pause you
know what I want to do but I can't do it
right
I want to play Knight F3 check and take
with the pawn but I can't do it uh
Knight F3 check Bishop takes Queen takes
well
well it's a second hold on uh maybe I
was just too enthusiastic four back okay
however Queen H5 is not that dangerous
well the thing is you can't take on e4
right because of F2 if you play Bishop
takes okay I was gonna trans I was gonna
try and exchange sacrifice on you
yeah
it's looking good night G4 plus F3 or is
that too much
to weaken it
now I'm really tempted by the whole Rook
sacrifice that's uh business because I
do have opinion we're gonna take on E8
first right give me Queenie right no I'm
not gonna help you out
uh F2 chip F2
so I'm up a rook but I'm getting mated
good for me
uh are we let what's better than one
Rook okay there we go I think you have
Queen C2 here right away
oh that's devilish I was about to say I
was going to get on my running shoes no
that doesn't that does work actually you
can Checkmate me
oh yes oh that even my running shoes I
don't I can run but I can't hide
Queen C2 mate maybe this is a better
pattern
um it's looking scary for Bella how
scary is it uh Almira
it's quite scary when you analyze it
could have Judith let me show you a nice
idea here which she missed after Queen
C2 for example the computer makes a draw
here by Rook h8 you know so like if you
take on h8 then you're losing after
creating it so because I can exchange
the queens and like I had
two Rooks right yes I can oh there's a
lot yes give a few of those back
so and if you play uh King G6 here
that's how he suggests that you make it
it's not human it's a very nice idea yes
so like if you take here then Queen
eight
King and then yes and then I'm trying
just to give checks all the time so like
you cannot go anywhere else so I will
play but after rookie six could I have
played King G5 that's the
the second continuation so you can play
King G5 here but then look at the screen
G6 check come on
it's not fair
it's not over yet that's why fireworks
you you asked me for the fireworks Rook
G6 again so I want you to be on this
square and then Queen it a simple
Perpetual very very easy to say sorry
very easy exactly but I I like this
variation very much but I think that
here after Rook E1 the main idea
especially is um to take on B7 so let's
say if you play Knight G4 or Knight F3
because I try to analyze Knight to three
first so you'll take and take because I
was thinking meat that's okay computer
is ruthless he takes on B7 and he thinks
that one weight is much better there is
no way for me to bring this Rook to H5
and the pound only four well
he's trying to well continue like this
five so maybe I can even take on C7
let's see
Rook C8 and well what
to do in this position I will keep my my
queen here so you will not be able to
take on C4s then I will take the rook
and well he defends rather precisely or
or claims that he has an advantage but
let's say after Knight G4 he also takes
the bomb Queen B7 and there is no uh
well
continuation here let's say if you try
E3 here then yes he plays F3
installs you so Knight F6 and he simply
he simply takes only three by the way I
think we have things hitting up in two
games so Elizabeth didn't find you a
mirror thank you yes thank you Amira
Elizabeth did find Bishop F7 right we we
were pounding the table for Bishop and
you can't take the bishop because I
didn't even try to take and play through
kj8 so now okay white is just up a pawn
and has a great position so and she just
said okay let me keep the bishop as you
say I'm at the pawn uh you got no
compensation and your king is the
vulnerable and you were about to tell us
about Nana another game Nana yes so she
had so many choices so many different
ways to win and I like the way she
played she went for the midi at night F5
rookie eight she months she didn't even
go for any of these variations with
Knight D7 uh that I found myself really
attracted to for some reason too I was
very attracted to the move Knight G4 she
just immediately went my
and look at the smoke we'll have six me
gusta I like this one Queen G4
uh and give me that Rook so
yes
thinking but I think every move should
be winning Queen D7 some geometry based
on Rook F7 and queen G7
um
okay six
Rook A6 didn't even see that one right
away how did you how did you spot Rook
A6 I mean I'm like
to be fair I thought I was winning a
piece
good good good good good good but I
think no no it is running I got lucky
okay six yes show me so if you take with
the queen of course I take Bishop B5
that's clear so let me just take it
tonight take with the night I have
Bishop takes E5 and then Bishop takes B7
so I'm still winning you dirty rat thing
and if I take it yes
you can do that
uh okay but I mean Rook takes F7 I I I
was drawn to the fact that the king is
so vulnerable and I saw the the
immediate Queen D7 was going to probably
provoke simply Rook f8 right
so uh
should I should I play Rook takes F7 and
queen D7 I I don't know I'm a
materialist I can take the Rook
um sorry we have some moves on the board
what did she play she took on E5 okay so
she's going for the prosaic Bishop takes
Queen takes just maybe back rank mate
Rook D6 yeah back rank
this is up in exchange so
yeah this is just a kind of an exchange
and has a great position so no need to
take on A6 by the way uh were do were
you ladies are you familiar with the
book Bobby Fischer teaches chess
no I know he's 60 best games my 60 best
games but there was a book Bobby Fischer
teaches chess which is arguably the most
best-selling book ever
chess book ever I mean it's well over a
million copies the only question is is
it close to 2 million copies but that
book
had one theme throughout the whole book
it was background mates
I read the book I said my God this guy's
a one-trick pony that's right he's in
the background mates but I'm looking at
this position after Queen takes E5 Rook
D6 the back rank mate I mean I'm
forcibly reminded of Bobby Fischer's
book and that's good enough backward you
know like all you need is one win per
game right Elmira yes and especially I
like
um Nana's a move Bishop B5 Queen E5 and
with the idea of playing Rook D6 because
it avoids all the complications you're
right it's the way to transform your
advantage and if you don't see a mate
then you simply can exchange a piece or
two and then win the game in the end
game right it's it's a very pragmatic
choice and it's very important for Nana
to win this game with white yes so she
she might join the leaders right
yeah and she's uh like Almira said
pragmatic practical choice and game is
over actually Nana is of course is she
represents the generation of uh Georgian
players you know which followed after uh
I think well my achiever they need the
nonaga printers and Alexandra
there were so many players so Nana plays
on the first Board of the Georgian team
for so many years and well it determined
me also that I grew up with the
negative industry and my children being
my Idols you know I had a photo of my
chipper they need the sign by Maya when
I was seven years old and wishing me uh
well a lot of nice victories and then I
I wanted to ask you because then the day
when I faced her in a super tournament I
couldn't believe my eyes and I I just
didn't know what to do with myself and I
didn't no uh actually like it was almost
what Jing described when he was playing
his first two games he was not there
because it was so important to me that
was such a magical moment that I almost
for forgot how to play chess overall I
was having my achievements in front of
me and like and the next day I was
playing uh nonaga printers really wow
yes but I still remember I've been like
Out of Body Experience exactly yes my my
soul was floating somewhere there and
but I was so happy and actually in this
tournament I drew against Maya and I
beat Nona and I think and I thought that
Nona actually I was completely lost but
I found a trick and I think that she was
going to kill me
I have a great story of Maya children
this is Seattle it has hosted the
Goodwill games and there was this
exchange of programs between the Soviet
Union and the United States so Maya
chipper and it's a on a Goodwill tour
came to play some of the of the girls in
Washington State
and she loved Seattle she thought it was
an incredibly beautiful city surrounded
by the mountains it was just really
really it was pristine at that exact
moment with great weather and I'd taken
her to my favorite Mexican restaurant
Casa Lupita
and she said yes sir this is great let's
have more tournaments in Seattle I want
to come back and I want to play and I
said I'm sorry Maya but here in Seattle
chess is not as popular as it is in the
Soviet Union nobody would know for
example who you are literally the words
just left my mouth Maya nobody would
know who you are the bus boy
excuse me could I have your autograph
please
are you kidding me
the timing was just too funny I mean we
cracked up I just lost it by the way
Rook F4 uh in the game of uh uh you're
right um Soviet Union of course chess
was so popular but especially in Georgia
women's chess
since I was born and growing up yeah we
have so many strong Grandmasters uh
female players and after gabrina the
Nana was the next exactly Grandmaster
that I was looking up to and right she's
been number one in Georgia since she was
a teenager since she was 14. right and I
I'm still very proud of this one of my
best games ever is building Nana with
the black faces I think that was my pick
Still Still fresh memory uh very good
okay we'll leave that uh Amira what
other we've lost a little bit track of
Arena's game how is she doing uh that's
actually what I wanted to tell you
because let's get back to this position
when Irina played Rook B8 and you
arrived rightfully assessed that black
is better but why black is better not
only because of the pawn structure and
the um and the pair of Bishops because I
was thinking that white normally uh
would be fine but you don't have a very
comfortable way of doubling your Rooks
on the C file so when hampi played here
Rook C2 I was thinking well it's a
silent draw offer actually because if
you play it night before Rook C1 Knight
D5 rooksito it's sort of a silent Rover
so let's have a look how the game
continue Arena played night before Rook
C1 Knight D5 Rook C2 here she understood
that hampi is fine with the draw so it
gives you a boost of confidence and I
think that Arena thought for a while and
she decided to continue nice as you so
she knows that she is better I'm not
sure that this is enough for the win but
psychologically she has an upper hand so
Irina played Rook B5
and then Knight C4 uh yes she doubled
her books on the B file Bishop G2
and here well king8 it's it's a very
fine move I really like Serena play and
Rook CC1 you know it's like white
doesn't know what to do and let's uh
what is the time right now because I
haven't since nine minutes for hampi and
10 minutes for Irina and Irina has a
much better position here and she has to
find this very interesting move C5 yes
after C5 computers think that she's much
better and she can actually win her
second uh game with the black piece wow
wow I mean when she Drew her number I'm
sure in her heart of hearts she thought
oh no starting with two blacks and in
one of the lower rated players in the
field that's not good winning with two
blacks that could sure uh cheer you up
as we prepare for break we have a
special
that we'd like to show you uh Eagle
Scout Bicentennial project by Dr Jeannie
singfield have a look
[Music]
in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parsons approved the building of a
life-size chess board to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a lifelong
patron of scouting in Great Rivers
Council board member proposed that the
project be built as an Eagle Scout
project Jeannie invited 16-year-old
Andrew doughton of troop 6 Jefferson
City to take on this incredibly
important project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chessboard
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite I
wasn't very familiar with the technology
needed to engrave on there so I needed
some assistance with that and learning
how to do it and after all that I'm
pretty sure I know how to do it now so
to engrave those Edge pieces I went down
to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we use the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
um it ended out to be a really really
cool project so we had a ribbon cutting
of the chess board and there were a
whole bunch of people there including
the governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project
Jeannie was there I had to give a little
speech that I didn't really know I had
to do but that kind of of has taught me
a little bit about speaking too so I
think that has helped me too this
project it's made me real proud that
everyone is enjoying it like every time
I go down there somebody's playing
um and then they're taking care of it
which really makes me proud because me
thinking all that time and everyone else
that's helped me sinking in all that
time I like to see people use it but I
also like to see people appreciate it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hi we're back welcome back thanks for
joining us and we have some exciting
updates indeed uh we actually think Nana
has just won the game essentially and
yeah well as you said yeah perfectly
perfectly timed this move Rook E3 E2
forces a trade of Rooks and since I said
oh dear she she crashes to her second
loss in a row as uh Nana win in a draw
yes transfer is a bad start but she's a
young player she still has seven rounds
to go so I'm sure she's gonna come back
but we're expecting a number of decisive
games when we left it we saw Elizabeth
it's just it's a dream position uh what
she's achieved currently it's like you
you would have these uh books that you
know like uh how to win in chess right
this would be a diagram position uh
forgetting the fact that White's
actually protected past Pawn up which is
already very very nice the Knight is
formidable uh versus the passive Bishop
the white white has material
does not look very good happy there
Elizabeth in great shape when we left it
also
um we thought Arena was doing quite well
but we no longer feel that way she's
allowed it looks it really did we
thought that she was going to play for
the move C C6 C5 which she did she
achieved that but at the end of the day
maybe it was the move Rook d8 that
because what happened is this move
Knight E3 compelled her to play Bishop
takes E3 King takes E3 and there went
the advantage and uh we think a draw
might be inevitable what's happening in
the game between our two co-leaders
uh Alexandra and harika right we also
have uh opposite color Bishop end game
and it looks more even now than it did
before yeah well we thought harika might
be the one pressing but I just saw in
the last few moves it was actually
Alexandra Alexandra who refused the
repetition she played b2b3 and let's
catch up to date on their position Rook
takes H7 and here we are I'm imagining
the move Bishop E3 and I think she
refused the draw because look at Black's
Bishop on Asics I was about to say yeah
harika is not not a bishop right now uh
the question next to the game can I play
D5 or not
here because I I'm seeing this idea that
The Rook might be able to involve uh
penetrate on F1 so can I play D5
looks good Almira maybe you can jump in
10 minutes I can maybe unravel a few
Mysteries here okay actually I was
looking at a more human move here let's
say after rocket seven for example I was
thinking Bishop B3 okay yes but then I
wanted to attack the B3 Pawn because you
have no means to protect it so it's sort
of a race let's see Rook H6 for me group
B3 this is G6 I like the move D6 because
I can always protect it with this in
this manner but then look at the C4 bomb
so I think
Alexandra has to calculate this position
precisely the computer evaluates it's of
course at zero zero but it's not that
easy for me for example let's have a
look at this line King F2 I will
certainly most certainly take on C4 yes
sir because I start to have bad habits
you know taking pounds everywhere the
training is working okay and now H4
Alexandra has to create the counter play
and she has this powerful two passer so
what can you do here let's go yes let's
go let's say Rook B1 in order to well to
have the possibility to stop this bound
so but you can also give the check okay
three yes because otherwise you look and
so well it's still equal because here
and I would like to yeah the computer is
looking at the move H6 very attractive
for me it is not so obvious here
so you see in order to understand that
this position is equal after Rook B8 she
needs to find this sequence of move and
to move them to give up the bishop by
the way Bishop G3 was Alexandra's Choice
she didn't play Bishop E3 okay let's
that invites Rook F3 though doesn't it
she just made move 40 by the way that
was her 40th 40th move so she'll get the
her extra a lot at times Rook G3 is
probably more precise because you can uh
you no longer may play D6 a very
important uh Nuance you can see why
Alexandra won all of these tournaments
the world championship the World Cup so
even on the Move 40 where very often you
make a mistake and then you regret it
let me just yes apologies to interrupt
you for just a moment as those two
players make time control Ana zatonski
uh as usual uh time trouble is impacting
that game what is the clock times
30 seconds and 30 seconds about two
minutes and they still have eight moves
to make yeah sorry to interrupt you on
that one Almera but this game is
completely fine and
[Laughter]
sometimes when I was this when I was
here your our team captain it was like
Anna Anna
here we go here we go that's right we
were definitely more nervous than
everybody but she's the calmest at the
board and we're all panicking right
what's going on in the current position
A5 is hanging Rook is hanging Queen came
back to C8 was that oh because she's
hitting C4 I see so she's defending her
pump
because I can take on A5 and then on B7
right okay let's have a look so Queen C8
if I capture you can capture right I'll
capture and this is the B7 that there is
an A2
at the end of if the whole shebang
right so she's keeping the material
balanced but whoa whoa whoa whoa this
queen is on the long diagonal makes
Perpetual checks hard and she does have
it the passer so Anna's not out of the
wood Yeah Anna is not out of the woods
Bella
and also we have an update that Irina
and happy are racing to a drone because
they've exchanged their Rooks right now
they are in opposite color bishop and
game exactly they will look for a
three-time repetition and uh they're
also in time trouble but in this
position nothing to discuss it's just
too easy
and to update the results as we have as
we're nearing the time control we have
one result
started with the draw she means that
she's not necessarily our tournament
leader not yet but not yet not yet I
will never will only time will tell if I
can borrow Christians a signature line
uh boy uh it's really looking terrible I
mean it was looking terrible but it
continues to look terrible for goodness
has an update for us Amira
I'm I'm just amazed really amazed look
at this position and now Alexander has a
move which is proposed by the computer
and if she finds it she might be winning
and this is okay six
let's go let's go King A6 then G5 you
know computer evaluates that these two
plus pounds are much better than an
exchange and uh well he actually thinks
that Alexandra is much better here and
maybe with a precise defense you will be
able to make a draw but here let's say
we will make a very simple move Rook B6
I will stop white from playing G6 and
then he simply brings uh the king no she
the blunder woman she brings the king
king too let's say Rook G6 it's just an
idea but I'm Amazed by those ideas in
the end game so H4 I protect the Palm
let's say we I don't even know what can
we do here let's say bring the king and
so here you see the evaluation the
skyrocketing yes so the best move in
this position he thinks is Rook G7 but
then you bring your king as well so and
the game continues with white is much
better so I wanted to draw your
attention attention to this absolutely
stunning move if Alexandra will you find
it uh this is a real game changer but by
the way I would find myself attracted to
the move Rook takes A6 because of the
two connected past pawns and I know that
the Rook actually against two connected
past Pawns in a bishop does not fare
well so Rook A6
intuitively but let me just bring the
key here is that Black's King is
absolutely terrible on Asics precisely
if it was anywhere in the center I would
in the king side I wouldn't be
considering it but the the I would say
Rook A6 King A6 G5 the the the the move
that I would I I I'd hesitate
is the move Rook F3 why does Rook F3
cause me to hesitate because the whole
idea that uh Amira was saying King E2
King E3 is stopped right secondly G
I know your idea but I think just Bishop
E5 and then you can't stop my h-bomb
but you're right wow h4h wow so even
that so it goes for it it's it's she's
intuiting something right here because
uh she's sensing like well the other
reason why would you play Bishop Rook
takes A6 because you're facing Bishop
takes C4 gosh don't it right right if
you don't play for a win that's your
only chance right and you don't want to
see Bishop take C4
E3 and Rook B1 and like hello I mean the
tables are complete completely turning
around right and that's why Rook A6
nice I and uh we have special guests in
studio with Almera
uh welcome Nana congratulations that was
a really fine win uh well please tell me
how do you feel in St Louis by the way
what time did you wake up today
today yeah it was Improvement I woke up
at 4 30 I think
what was yesterday 3 30. did you manage
to sleep a little bit before they gave
you yeah okay so that's that was an
improvement yeah before the game I'm
trying to to get some sleep one hour
sleep maybe yeah otherwise it's it's
impossible okay so let's have a look at
the at your game it was a very
interesting opening and I think yeah I
don't know if you remember you already
played this line against Elena danilan
yeah yeah I usually play this line time
to time yeah so at critical moment I
think it was in exactly in this position
when she took Bishop D3 I think um what
did you think she was supposed to be she
should have played Bishop F3 I think
Bishop F3 Bishop F3 and he takes it
three
uh if takes E3 Knight D3 Knight D3
Queen D3
Bishop B7
Rook B8
and here yeah I was thinking where to go
with this picture on F3 or I think on if
three because yeah yeah
uh and the hero black has I think very
interesting options like playing C4 with
the idea Bishop C5 uh Rook d8 yeah
um so I think
um objectively it must be equal because
I have Bishop D force it takes b38xp3
yeah yes the computer actually agrees
with your information by the way it's
sorry to interrupt you Amira but uh we
do
no no uh
draw right so uh here two of us actually
I wanted to ask you if you were
calculating this move because now that I
look at this line the computer offers
Queen S3 yes maybe yes and what about
night City
you know this is not the line that is
probably easy to calculate this is
really I mean strange this computer
evaluation sometimes is really confusing
I don't know no of course the line that
you offered is more human than I with
you you know this was probably the best
continuation for black so let's have a
look after Bishop j3 yeah after uh Rook
D1 I already liked my position very much
and and yeah when she went to Bishop A6
it takes D4 please continue
after Knight D4 I thought my position is
already winning here because my pieces
are very active
95 is a threat so yeah but there was so
many options for me to how to I mean how
to win the game that I was calculating
then I and then I saw and I was very low
on time and finally I made I managed to
convert this Advantage actually and as
you mentioned that the most difficult
thing for her in this position would be
that there are so many options do you
find it difficult from time to time
because your eyes are looking everywhere
yes because I was calculating I missed
so many lines and yeah finally I think I
I I've chosen that which was the
simplest I just took exchange and then
yeah converts to the simplest way
um Nana this is your third time that you
play in the sentence so you played every
Edition so I well welcome back of course
so tell us a little bit why do we like
this tournament
yeah I mean uh here I feel really
special because everybody it feels like
everybody loves and respects our game
and yeah it's always very pleasant for
me to come here and play
so you are certainly trying to do your
best and well this question which
doesn't have to do anything with chess
well of course everyone is dressing
really elegantly we have a dress code
but I was thinking Hmm okay how many
shoes do you have how many pair of shoes
do you have
I didn't expect such a question
actually
when I came when I came from home I had
three pairs of shoes but then I went to
Germany I played the tournament in
Germany and there I was three more so
then I went to Nicosia and then I also
bought some more so some seven pairs of
shoes so I was not so off you know we
describing at home how many let's say 20
30. I mean yeah many more yes I just
wanted to to ask a fun question because
I think it's it's uh well we have so
many beautiful images and like all the
players are very elegant so thank you
very much Nana We Wish You A lot of
success in this tournament and well hope
to see you again thank you maybe yes sir
has a question oh just our
congratulations a very very nice Victory
to get today we really liked the harmony
of your attacking forces so continue
absolutely continue good play
and our results and we're expecting more
more decisive games coming up right so
far we have two results Nana won a
beautiful game against Abdul Malik and
the cornero and crash have drawn their
game arena had an easy day as she was
slightly better with black maybe she
could have pressed a little bit more to
a start of two blacks for arena she
scored one and a half very very nice but
they worse this over for her absolutely
and Elizabeth uh Elizabeth has just
played a crushing move Queen takes D6
with a check that's the second Pawn by
the way and this is no this is just no
good way of answering this move keeping
in mind that The Rook if you put your
King on A7 Rook is coming to G7 check
and something like this is no fun either
this is naidorf gone bad for black very
well put and Knight or done gone very
bad in this move Queen takes D6 looks
like lights out which means what is
going on in that Bella versus
wow Anna actually got a pawn up in a
rook and pawn ending we thought she was
going to be suffering in time Scrabble
and I ended up out playing Bella exactly
and we now have a rook end game where
she's up a pawn I believe it's a draw
but black is the one playing for a win
exactly this was uh this was the
position where we we more or less
expected Queen takes A5 the end of which
was a better Queen ending even material
for white but what she did instead
she allowed black screen to get very
active
and did what Nasi
White had a queen A5 here I think I was
about to say what do you think about the
pawn grub Queen takes A5 that would have
been enough for equality or I think so I
see a perpet
well black can still be a pepon after
Queen A5 Rook takes A5 yeah oh Rook C2
and Rook takes A2 okay so Queen A4 ah
very good excuse me so you're right it's
still a pawn it's still a pawn but he
can play Rook C7
is a draw right well isn't that the game
we saw the other day uh
[Laughter]
okay but uh Anna for Choice uh she's got
the Sunny Side of a rook and pawn and me
uh the current position she's upon up
she's made time control so Anna as you
said I'll played her opponent in the
time trouble and Alexandra's still
thinking I'm sure about Rook takes Asics
a huge moment and for Alexandra if she
were to win this game
um two out of two two out of two with
the white pieces and defeating two of
her strongest rating wise right rivals
in
um Eureka and hampi Rook takes A6 it's a
beautiful move it just basically says
look I'm giving up an exchange but look
what remains a bishop and two connected
past pawns and as you pointed out so
importantly the black king is nowhere
near these passers keeping in mind that
the look I had one idea here since if
black plays this passively they don't
have a chance right exactly so why not
try D5 and create in a passport let's do
it let's have a look D5 let's take it
and um C4 I am presuming
and by the way uh Elizabeth has one
beautiful game
I think she just crushed the night off I
would not play nightrift again well
Bishop takes F6 I didn't like the
decision of G takes F6 that recapture
after that recapture seemed like a
downhill
um uh as we see the players and once
again just to refresh our results page
we have a third result Elizabeth just
beat uh gunai mamazada and Nana won her
game against Abdul Malik and conero and
crash through their game exactly and
we're looking at the game of Alexander
Costa new will she sacrifice The
Exchange and you are about to suggest
that desperate times call for desperate
measures let's go for it right let's go
for C4 okay and let's go G6
I don't like that your king is so close
to my sipon it's true right it's true
but what I had in mind was I was
thinking that my Bishop could also in
like if you go C3 right and this is done
it
I tell you these world champions have
some there's something special about
them they they really they haven't
a sixth sense I I I I I've seen it with
Vichy I've seen it with Gary Talia of
course he just they they stopped
suddenly in mid mid thought mid mid
track and they go oh you know I could do
this and it's like oh my gosh how did
you come up with that but I think what
she was assisted by something that's
very very important the threat of Bishop
C4 and E3 you could probably convinced
her that this was I mean as she gets
over the Euphoria like I'm willing I'm
winning I'm winning I have no choice
I'm winning but I gotta take on A6 shall
we finish the line G5 D5 no I think I
was ready to resign in that life oh
really it was like 56 I don't see how
I'm much slower so it's not even close
is that the problem you could also
played Just Bishop F4
or even now Bishop F4 I I was going to a
lot okay now Bishop F4 here
at least I'm I'm kicking a little bit
right that could have played King F2
then maybe okay uh oh that's nasty so
Rook check King F2
but E3 check E3 check now this is here
we go G5 will she find D5 desperate
Amira Desperate Times Desperate Measures
D5 we're we're doing our best to find
some kicking chances for harika does it
help
you do
D5 of course you take C takes D5 C4 it's
a race but after G6 C3 you can make a
simple move King D1 just bring the king
closer don't allow well black to play C2
and here okay you you will have to try
and stop the pawn
can play Rook B7 but then you will have
Bishop B5 because actually in the line
that you suggested after G7 uh um it's
already draw already draw yes because he
He suggests uh well he plays on King F2
there is E3 right yeah not deep thought
here he goes for C2 oh even C2 works but
now he's three yes that's why that's the
uh the very important idea here so I
still don't get it Bishop takes you
through well he goes here
of course so that's for him is a draw
but which is not so obvious to our right
the minds are pure Mortals but
um here after King divon I think it's
much easier yeah King D1 it really uh
that's that's because the bishop
controls the E1 Square so just in case
if you if you push E3 okay you can go uh
G7 let's say E2 or we can take or you
can but we can even take here
yeah and that move Bishop G3 by the way
is becoming more and more a star move
right because it it stops The Rook from
coming behind the G Pawn when the G Pawn
gets going and time the players have
made their time control right the first
time 44 so they've gotten their 30
minute bonus and that move Rook takes A6
so I guess at this point best try for
harika is to passively defend maybe go
Rook B6 after G5 Rook to B6 after G5 and
Almira was showing us King E2 I think
yeah
um okay I like that move King E2 I mean
just cozying up the board and H4 H5 is
also on the agenda right maybe King B7
King C8 trying to finish the pawns okay
fair
uh King E8 King E8 well push
afraid
and as we uh as we have fun with our
race we actually have a guest in studio
over to you Elmira Elizabeth uh hersley
will come in yes that's why I'm sure
welcome to Elizabeth pets she just won a
beautiful game against good night
Elizabeth well tell us a little bit more
about this game it was quite a
complicated one and you found a
beautiful idea later in the game so so
actually like Bishop B7 was the first
move which was kind of surprising she
had a game with H6 actually enough the
H6 the main move is Bishop H4 but
there's also Bishop takes F6 which leads
to something crazy but if black knows it
well then it's nothing for White and the
funny part is like from the psychology
point of view she had a game instead of
Bishop B7 she had a game with H6
and after Bishop takes off six uh take
on F6 with Bishop
H4
I think B4 and according to the engine
it's better for black she lost this game
because of one tiny mistake which
happened later
but the funny part is like that somehow
she was yet scared even though so light
is nothing for white social you analyzed
it precisely no this line I analyzed I
wouldn't have played like this because I
know that this line gives nothing and I
was sure that after she lost to blue
marker she would have improved on that
but somehow like she was thinking for 20
minutes and moved bishop p7 and now I
was passing before to do because I
didn't know what to do in fact because
um there is some line instead of Bishop
instead of Rook B8 that played Bishop B7
instantly and now I choose F5 but the
point about F5 here is that for example
like after E5 what she played in the
game this is normal Bishop takes F6 I
think according to my knowledge Bishop
takes F6 is the strongest move and here
the problem is like now that actually
like she has the tempo
um I have a temple office Bishop G2 in
fact because there is this position with
Rook A8 and Bishop F1 but the point is
that the bishop on G2 happens to be
worse on G2 then on F1 because now if I
go Knight F3 which is one of the
engine's moves but not here in a
different line then after Knight P6
Knight C4 it's not convenient so here
actually I have to go Knight B3
so likely I understood that uh
um well it gives nothing so I mean I'm
sure that after Bishop B7 F5 is somehow
wrong but the other line which I checked
instead of F5
what was interesting
um
is to play H4 here so basically to
convince her that after age six Bishop
takes F6 Bishop takes step six instead
of you know instead of Bishop B7 then B4
was the best move but now she already
moved Bishop B7 and I was thinking maybe
I can improve that but the problem is
like if I play G5 here I thought she
takes on D4
and then plays E5
and I was not sure about that
even though the computer I see likes it
but I still was not sure about that so
this was the second option I saw but
there were a lot of complications yes
were you surprised by this decision well
no because I had a similar game against
her like many years ago in 2017 where
she also like in the same line tend to
take with a Pawn on F6 so she kind of
likes that
and I had a similar position with black
against bull marker as well where I was
totally lost in the Grand Prix I managed
to win this game with Mario so I thought
like okay this position is easier to
play for white it's okay so what was the
next critical moment I think the most
critical moment is a move 21 okay let's
have a look when she played H5
and after age five I mean like I wasn't
sure like I mean the thing is like she
lost a little bit the crib because she
lost the in the moment when she
played Knight c492 and Knight B6
actually because maybe she was hoping
for a draw but somehow I sensed in this
moment that she didn't know what to do
so I played Rook C1 in order to
prophylactically protect and after H5 I
was also not sure what to do I played G5
which is also the best move according to
the engine she took on G5 and I took on
H5 so I played well I see so good
and here I thought she should go
um not Bishop F6 but maybe she should
just go Um
G4 yes it was uh well it's suggestion by
the computer before then I play f60 F6 I
would have played no maybe she should
take on H4 actually because if you're
like tactically like worse you should
grab the material then you play F6 and
they always have six so she played F6
Bishop F6 herself which I think was
still probably the best move practically
speaking
and now I didn't know what to do I
played group G1 and I couldn't decide
whether I go Rook G3 or Rook G1 but did
you find this idea uh beforehand when
you did you think that after Rook G1 if
she plays King E7 you already had this
idea your mind takes up seven I saw many
times already but I didn't have and when
she played King E7 I uh I then I
understood something like Bishop F7 and
immediately took on C5 so this was
obviously like the main plunder
and the funny part is like that after
Bishop takes F7 the most critical line
is Bishop takes D2 I was calculating F6
and I was calculating Bishop E6 and the
game I would have played Bishop E6
because I'm like too lazy to calculate
too much and I was sure this was a nice
move of course but Bishop B6 is winning
the computer says that after this uh a
black is hopeless here but of course
it's it's not obvious because this was
not I saw this line as well but I
wouldn't have played it I would have
played Bishop E6 here because just by
intuition
Bishop E6 and I think here
um for example like if she takes one C3
I have something like Queen G2 Rook
she's three something like that and I
was sure I was winning so I didn't even
know what she would do here after Queen
G4 yes sure I mean look she's frequency
for something but something like on the
cheaper
okay so and let's get back to to the end
of the game I think that it was rather
hopeless after yes maybe I could have
wanted quicker but somehow I wanted to
play it safe after yesterday
so I just think like uh ka5 here you can
do anything and she resigned but uh many
options here Elizabeth well that was a
fine game I think from many points well
everyone knows that you're sending me
the messages at five in the morning so
everyone hopes that you're going to
sleep better uh tell me so what do you
do then after you know I have a great
morning because I wake up at five and
I'm totally awake so it's the most uh
funny part okay it's obviously jet lag
but on the other hand like I fall asleep
at nine o'clock so I think it's uh it's
very fine but at five o'clock I'm
reading for one hour then at like 6 30 I
get impatient so I wake up my boyfriend
then at seven o'clock I take a coffee
and then at eight o'clock I go to swim
for one hour because at nine o'clock
already a lot of kids are coming so you
don't have your piece and then actually
around nine nine thirty I slowly start
to prepare so how important it is to
include the physical preparation into
your daily routine
um usually like you know
um I'm not doing sports during the
tournament but the pool is so nicely
heated that I can't resist to use a
chance and I don't think that swimming
takes too much of my energy because I'm
not screaming like a athlete or like a
wool Champion I'm swimming like a calm
old little fashion girl so
um I would call it the grand mom styles
kind of swimming obviously so yes and
after the swimming actually like uh yeah
I'll I would usually prepare if I mean
today I prepared at like six o'clock a
little bit and then maybe at nine
o'clock but anyway
um it didn't happen on the board what I
was expecting thank you Elizabeth uh yes
sir Nazi do you have a question uh just
our congratulations Elizabeth a very
very fine game indeed and uh we thought
you were just playing a really great
game a beautiful game yeah yeah keep it
up
compliments compliments and once again a
refreshing our result table
we have three results so far so far
corner Drew their game so I need to
defeated up to Malik and Elizabeth pets
defeated Mama Zara a little bit bad news
for her commentary team here as we're
looking at the game of Anna sutonski
it's a rook ending that might go just
like in yesterday's last round game that
might go for quite some time but we're
still a buzz with this game of Alexandra
where she sacrificed The Exchange and
she's played this move G5 and she's
basically saying hey my two my two
passers and Bishop are gonna overwhelm
your Rook we you did something that was
at least you were keeping in the game
you were playing Rook here
and I moved my king and I move my king
and you somehow brought your king all
the way around now should I have been
playing H4 and getting on with business
so let's go King E2 King B7 let's get
rid if black doesn't bring the king over
it's just I can't stand with just the
Rook exactly so let's let me throw out
H4
the idea is obviously I want to play H5
and G6
well Rook G6 just encourages me yeah
Bishop F4 I'm thinking that you're going
to come down in order to
um
I don't know uh bring your Rook behind
okay I my intention why did I play King
E2 my intention was to and now I'm
threatening
G6
Almera Jump Right In on this uh I'm
thinking that two pawns and Bishops
should overwhelm The Rook but maybe it's
a little trickier than I thought
it's always tricky I had to look at this
position after H4 and computer
surprisingly suggests that after D5 well
the position becomes equal once again
wow for the human mind it's it's very
difficult so let's say if you continue
with H5 for example then he goes D4 and
I think he will also use this idea of to
give checks you know because now you're
deprived of all the squares so let's say
if you want to play Bishop before then
he gives checks you know he plays and
then King one and then he gives checks
so that's he he does not allow you to
play here because after this you're
suddenly losing with all respects I'm
not gonna let you play D4 I'm going to
take that yeah
well you could also continue here with
G6 just to illustrate how complicated
this position is it's almost like well
to understand the universe you you know
the quantum analysis gives zero zero but
I have no idea of what is going on so
after King E3 the computer suggests Rook
B2 so you see I don't know who's even
playing for a win
sorry two here yes king of four D2
wow oh we have yes on the board now on
your screen and then
Queen and let's have a look at this
position this should be winning for
black well but wait a minute come on you
just let the d-pawn go all the way from
D7 to D1 I mean let's take on D5 yes
please
so C takes D5 Rook B2 she takes D5 of
course this is probably the strongest
move in this position so where do you go
here if the finger three I will give you
another check and let's go up the board
King F4 King F4 now this one is starting
to run
this one yes let's let's try G6 and see
where it's actually goes then C3 because
now Bishop F4 yes exactly the king is
taking a very important square away from
this bishop so right then after G7 C2
and C1 is coming with check and you're
losing okay
King F4 is not possible but then let's
have a king E2 is wrong I should go like
King F2
Double Check Yes okay let's say King F1
but then check again where are you going
King G2
well King G2 you're going yes well I can
play C4 but I can first check King H3 I
just want to hide yes yes okay now
that's your king is the way
now this is a line where I get to play
Bishop F4 now seven let's go
four four are you gonna play E3
still still because now that the king is
on H3 I have your Rook B3 yes so amazing
and now you're you're losing one even
losing I shouldn't have taken on E3 I
should have made a queen but how
difficult it is to take those decisions
when you are under pressure and you have
to make those decisions now harika has
only 18 minutes left she still didn't
play Rook B6 but Rook B6 is just the
first move of the whole sequence okay
but Rook B6 I'm I'm beginning to shy
away from my decision to play King E2 so
Rook B6 right here should I be playing
H4 and let's go let's just push him
so this is where Almira was saying D5
right yes I was thinking no yes because
it was but I didn't include King E2 not
yet so we will start King E2 then well
no I'm saying I don't like King E2
because of the the D5 variations you
were showing on mirror so I'm starting
with uh in in the game position no
Bishop G3 I'm trying to play D5 though
and give you a rook B1 check
well I I didn't I win a Tempo with h35
with the Rook on B6 okay I took us Rook
be one check
and now I can decide where I I mean a
moment ago my king was on E2 now I can
decide where to put my king right
so I've got D2 as a possibility
as well as F2
a little bit different a different
wrinkle I think but is it better I don't
know I really don't know right now I'm
like Almira I'm contemplating the
universe and the quantum mechanics of uh
our uh not deep blue
so what is the sense of Life yes sir
right exactly exactly uh I'm gonna gonna
refer to Mont uh
life is actually on your screen it's
0.00 and it's not 42. wow I thought Rook
A6 was at the decisive blow
and I jumped the gun
D5 is actually a serious counter play
provided harika plays the move
yes I'm not getting really confused
let's have a look after Rook B6 well why
can't she just play D5 immediately then
if why do I need Rook B6
so H4 isn't played and that makes a
difference I think so I mean H4 now with
the so if I just start with D5 but we
analyzed this line before yes sir yeah I
suggested this and it was yes because
you simply take yeah
you know and then uh well after C4 yes
we analyzed that they have this King D1
do you remember G6 C3 King D1
ah yes that was a very important
inclusion in our
um analysis
rugby six I think still the best move is
King E2 here for white okay and maybe
you should try something here you wanted
to try Nancy King B7 yes it's quite
complicated to run I actually like this
move you should bring your king closer
so let's see how computer hesitates
immediately after King B7 it's not that
clear for him if white is winning so He
suggests King E3 and he continues with
this idea he plays King seed so maybe
this is the way for black to hold this
game just to give away the spawn so King
E4 and King d8
and G6 here G6 I still I'm still writing
time H4 yes this is the position that
you are looking for and now the computer
says only B1 yes the only move
wow
um so he's hoping I will first of all to
attack the opponent to give the checks
for example H5 right natural age five
then you can start with Rook H1 and then
play Rook with one but okay Rook H1 you
have to bring your king somewhere so I
think that King G5 you will have Rook G1
anyway so it's a draw so you will have
to move to G4 and now maybe King G8
so what do you think
wow I yes how is this not lost I know I
thought the two pass bonds and the
bishop but somehow that was magic I mean
it's almost study like how did the King
which was on the other side of the board
ever managed to get to G8 I mean that's
black magic the King on A6 gets to G8
before I even get to go
no no no no that's amazing so Rook B6
King E2 King B7
so why not start age I guess on H4 D5
again H4 D5
because in this case the king doesn't
arrive in time right H4 King C8 H5
the king is is way too slow right we
could just we just get to go H6 and H7
and we'll park our Bishop on E5 and
don't forget we've got a C4 upon D5
immediately yes you have to play D5
immediately because what's important to
understand about the move H4 that your
Bishop is going to be on priests so
actually harika didn't play Rook B6 she
played D5 immediately which I again
that's a very human move because your
instinct is my Rook
but you know you go passive you can't
hold it the two pawns and the bishop
will overwhelm The Rook so she's looking
for D5 and this is this is the point
that when you go for the C3 that move
King D1
just to stop and the bishop holds the E
Pawn as well Bishop G3 is turning out to
be a star move wow and what a start for
Alexandra I mean and yesterday she won a
beautiful game and she addressed this
little k-6 was such a nice move exactly
my goodness
um
D5 it turns out this very compelling
looking move is maybe the losing move
I'll mirror
indeed it's almost plus four so plus
four the and the variation is very
straightforward so you know it's not so
easy to calculate not so difficult to
calculate because you have to take on D5
no question yes no question with that so
C takes D5 and then black can continue
with C4 as we analyzed but after G6 once
again
C3 by King G1 is that the only winning
move by the way American d1g G2 well he
now he she eats you know we live in
in a different era you know so just D6
as well but then also I'm afraid the bit
yes that I will spoil it you know so yes
it might win as well but King D1 I like
it very much yeah
right and if Alexander were to pull this
off I mean and win uh against a key
rival she will be the only player to go
2-0 yeah
because uh
the other remaining game right the two
other players who coming into this round
were leading kunai lost her game and
exactly Irina Drew her game exactly so
wow
uh happy with their pick well you know I
mean yeah
just you know competitors
my my close Rivals see how it is you
know what can I say what can I say what
can I what can I say but uh you fixed
their luck after this oh my goodness I
think it was the jet lag
I mean waking up at four o'clock in the
morning our time that was tough uh but
yeah I have to uh congratulate to uh
Mira for her understanding her wisdom
her insights well too many games played
against Alexandra but and it's a very
very long tournament we shouldn't we
shouldn't count our chickens before they
come home jerus the other remaining game
come on let's give some attention to
Anna for a second because she's actually
Upon A lowest rated seed in the
tournament and really realistically true
but she loves positions like this who
doesn't yeah she's on the sunny side oh
actually I don't love it because I'm
happy Pawn but I know it's a draw so I
have to sit there and torture my
opponent for two hours but I'm also
torturing myself right because I know
it's not a win
so it's funny because for for for me I
look at it as
a challenge I agree with you that it's a
draw but I also think to myself
how could I make it as difficult as my
uh possible for my phone opponent to
find that draw now F7 F6 is not my
Approach my Approach is the only way I'm
going to win this game funnily enough is
on the queen side
it's really really weird but uh I ca I
can't just force through a passer on the
king side so in my heart I would love to
see my king for example on C3 or or A3
that would be anywhere on the queen
anywhere on the queen side so I would be
thinking about the move King okay four
that's the problem
I think you're off my Christmas wish
list wait a minute hold on I was hoping
that yeah I was hoping that you were
going to go down to the seventh and then
I was going you know what I was going to
do I was going but you're okay in that
case King F6 right so Rook F4 check I'll
go King E7 and I'll try to Scurry across
um to this but I think with F6 she has
same idea right she can go King F5 next
move
sorry F6 I think you're right that's her
intention King F5 uh does the computer
again on is upon up so like let's let's
cheer her on does the computer say
boring boring easy easy draw what does a
computer say uh America well he doesn't
say that it's an easy draw and I just
remember that I lost the name game
against the Chien bakra recently where I
was a pawn up and so I managed to lose
them all up yes
I don't know how he does it but let's
say here I tried the very human move
Abella just played A4 so but with the
similar idea I think because she wants
for example I tried B4 let's say you
play Rook E5 you take only five this and
A4 so I was thinking is this setup
completely drawish so it secures the
drawer not so let's see I can continue
like this so
something
which is very natural so what do you
think yeah so is it an easy draw
yeah it just still feels very very easy
we're gonna take a quick commercial
break and we're gonna see you on the
other side as our
uh coverage of round two continues will
take a break we'll be right back
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and welcome back everyone let's take a
look at our results so far we have two
decisive results that means and pets
have won their games and conero and
Crush Drew their game and it really
feels to us at this exact moment that
we're about to see two more decisive
games we thought that Anna's game was
heading towards a draw but Bella missed
an incredibly important point right here
huge blunder yeah after the move F7 F6
if she wanted to force a draw we think
the move B3 B4 right here right now was
the way to go she thought okay I'll
include the move A4 the next move I'm
going to trade a pair of Pawns but it it
was mistimed King F5 B4 does not work
Rook E4 and that's it that's game over
for her absolutely that's a decisive and
the current position two extra pawns
counted two
right and you're just gonna go Rook B4
and you just start pushing them both it
may be a snail's walk but it they make
that and it's Unstoppable yeah wow the
other game which has actually been an
absolutely marvelous marvelous game a
great fight Saw Alexandra
sacrificing in exchange and during our
break we were just taking a look at it
now see and we see the move King D3 uh
funnily enough we both jumped on the
same idea but in a different way you you
like G6 I said well Rook D5 and you said
well H4 H4 just taking away the G5
Square for The Rook you ready to go
and I said oh yes of course G7 Rook here
Bishop to G Bishop to E5 protecting and
then I'm ready to go H4 and boom boom
boom so we both push them get and she's
done it she's played G6 Rook takes D5
now
what do you think H4 or G7
I think both
right but H4
you just it's safer right it's not
allowing Rook G5 altogether
oh she listens to you well I tell you I
mean
these players are really really good
did you know that was coming you were
laughing before
coming in
but I liked H4 too so I mean I'll give
you I'll give you full credits on that
one yeah G7 on the board and what what
are you gonna do you have to play five
years right and then the bishop comes
maybe I can include E3 check it doesn't
change much but it's a check uh check
his check yeah uh let's go for C4 let's
do it and this is the problem it's the
two connected past pawns it's not just
this guy right
yeah here I don't know what to do yeah
you're just yeah agreed agreed but okay
uh is there any trickies that you see
out there we we haven't discovered them
ourselves we think G7 as well as H4 H4
in your opinion was a safer win or was
okay Alexander's Choice safe I think
that G7 is a more human approach but uh
both moves win okay so H4 were just as
good just seven years is just as good I
tried H4 here so there's not much that
you can do because you can no longer
play Rook G5 C4 G7 so you have to go
back Rook d8 and then first of all you
stop so you Bishop B5 you have to stop
the C Pawn so why not to play G7
immediately but both variations win so
yeah and then Rook G5 Bishop E5 as
expected let's have a look Rook d8
Bishop B5 is on the board no it's my
version no no sorry I'll just let me
yes okay so Rook G5 Bishop E5 and the
whole point here is you can't take the
bishop that's a queen and you can't move
away
C4 right away okay C4 with or without E3
you're welcome H4
no it's a three see never mind it
doesn't work no C3 I will take the rook
and I still have Bishop H4 and Bishop F4
and Bishop B2 I liked your E3 just to
throw me a curveball I can't take
the the pond because of the bishop but
the problem is
is now I can I I can't make any progress
at all and just wait for you to promote
exactly
um that was a very very unfortunate uh
moment in the game of Bella there where
she has missed Rook E4 and again it's
like one of those things
you know you you did she just let down
her guard she just thought okay I've got
this drawn I'm just going to play the
move B4 and you know could you explain
that one for us because obviously she's
such a strong player you shouldn't make
that kind of a blunder Almira well but
this is a clear indication of a poor
form if I might say because I know that
it happened to me very often that well
you think that draw is Within Reach and
that's why I actually started here with
before before Bella made her move
because I thought that it was very
important to simplify this position yes
to get I don't know you can take but
they think if you take then it's even
easier because then you can stabilize
this with
A4 and then after rookie five you take
on A5 and you play A4 so I thought that
this position is very easy to defend and
Bella probably wanted to transpose to
this position but after A4 which
computer considers to be a very
important error so of judgment
and then after King F5 he thinks that
okay black is already winning wow
so
um I think that well there is no way
that Bella can save this game now
because after rookie for computer says
look at the evaluation that black is
having a completely winning positions
right almost plus six yes yeah the two
Pawn
and by the way for uh American chess
fans where I have to say it being a
little uh nationalistic cheering our
American women because she would win as
the lowest seed she Drew her first game
against Nana and so she's sitting there
saying ladies it's nice to be here she's
doing really well and she's doing very
very well indeed exactly so
and today
she managed her time super well maybe
that's safety
yeah we're talking Ann as a town you're
talking Anna satonski right I managed
her time really well well I have called
quite a number of U.S championships uh
and I can't recall ever using that
phrase uh with Anna that she's using her
time really well here at the two past
ponds are uh they're stealing the show
it's it's again it may look like a
snail's pace but Rook before a for you
know you have to move the Rook away Rook
A3 Rook B3 A3 it's slow and slow and so
and so it goes I like your arrows yeah
right as a kind of Space Invaders as
they go up the board back to uh
uh Bishop E5 King E3 how do you not play
H4 there
that is really
she's like I'm gonna win with just one
Pawn
I'm just gonna
uh wow uh
just a second hold on I'm trying to I'm
trying to understand was she afraid of
okay if she had gone age four Rook H5
she was probably worried about ether
check
okay let's let's see yeah the curveball
right before yes yeah the E3 check now
I've been playing King E2 and I don't
see any reason why not to continue
no she couldn't have been
well maybe could she have been afraid of
King
Porsche five King difa you know what I
wear a queen Coming yeah I'm trying yeah
I don't think I'm gonna hang and but
okay King E3 was her choice uh I'm sure
that's still winning is that the case
though yes yes okay King E3 yeah just
King E4 well for Alexandra again you
know she didn't start really amazing
really amazing and by the way King E3
King C6 on the board now H4 or even King
E4 should be enough but
uh tickle The Rook get the Rook away H4
Rook G4 H5 it would be some miracle if
somehow like
King gets to G8 on time
and then it's a draw right okay here's
here's maybe where there might be
something right takes here takes
queen king here
I should still be winning I mean I'm
sure it's a table base win yeah but
maybe
okay maybe just E4
but like you say I just don't want to
see the king Landing I don't want to see
the king land on by the way it's like
you think that it's the right color
Bishop otherwise yes that would be Rook
G7 at some point right so here let's say
I go Rook G1
you know
I I'm almost tempted just to tuck my
king in just so you don't have to you
can play H5 that's true
yeah so in age one Temple behind for
black wow on Rook G7 just h8
important not to take the Rook right
nice wow okay but yeah I mean what a
window of opportunity to take Soul lead
for Alexandra she came on yesterday and
she's had such great successes in her
life and her career and now Mary you
were just asking her what does it mean
for victory it it was an interesting
answer she gave it was like more of a
relief
than Victory what was her actual quote
do you recall well actually Alexandra
said that well these victories now have
a completely different flavor because
she really enjoys them now she Savers
well before it was sort of a given if
you win it's it's a relief you know but
if you suffer a defeat it's it's almost
like a small death you know so you were
trying to avoid this situation by
winning a tournament but you didn't
really enjoy it and here we see a former
world's Women's Champion 2008 2010 but
it's not just that I mean I'm thinking
two decades at the very very top I mean
she's played every event she's won I
have maintained
being a top player exactly for two
decades exactly yes and she won the
World Cup recently so right right I'm
still amazed by every performance
2021 yes
yes so okay uh King E3 on the board and
uh again for those of you joining this
late once again shame on you but there
was this absolutely stunning moment
right here where we thought with the
Bishops of opposite color position that
it wouldn't have surprised us if this
game was going to end in a draw Ameris
said stop right here there's a moment we
went what and she found it Rook takes A6
giving up the next change to play bishop
and two Pawns protected two pass pawns
against the rook and from that exchange
sacrifice we
bring our our viewers to the game
position she included H4 or pardon me
that was my move that's ceremony on the
board yet we're we're thinking that King
takes eight E4 is the clean win followed
by H4 and that exchange sacrifice was
oh H4 okay wait a minute let's let's
double check group G4
and I'm assuming H5 uh King D5 can you
spend a Tempo just moving the bishop
just to not let you take the bishop
uh you scared me you said if I get my
king to G8
and
if it worked you but you don't get to
keep the G8 this is eight seven you're
right Bishop yeah just move the bishop
H4 the the position is Rook G4 right now
H5 King
boy talk about moving the how ooh how oh
that's nasty Bishop F6
threatens Bishop G5 oh nice right oh
that's that's stylish
that's devilish yeah that's her Personal
Touch wow I like it I like it Almera
Bishop F6 very nice touch very study
like right so now Rook G6 is the only
move and then
I'm encouraged to play the H5 and that
move Bishop F6 didn't see it but uh it
once you once you see the idea of Bishop
G5 you go sweet as we heard yesterday
she loves studies and does a lot of
tactics and studies almost every day so
it shows well indeed just her decision
to play H4 doubtlessly right here King
takes E4 we thought was clean H4 but
once you see
H4 combined with Bishop G5 as she did
then you say I like it nice I think we
might see a resignation right here
exactly blacks out of options and if I'm
reading the clocks correctly almost out
of time too only two minutes two minutes
left for harika and seven for Alexandra
now once again
for Alexandra the two Indian ladies are
two of the highest rated players in the
field right I mean that's right in the
middle pardon me Alexandra's right in
the middle of the second yes yeah but uh
for sure humpy's the highest rating
player in the field and we we showed the
live rating list what that meant but
once again this is the uh the ratings of
the players yes by rating so hump is
number one Alexander number two and
harika number three so in the first
round she played number one and number
three and there's two oh yeah for the
rest of field that's like scary right
wait a minute you know you just beat two
of the highest rated players you're
sorry to say running away with the
tournament in a way but again let's not
forget that Alexandra started with two
whites versus Arena Crush starting with
two blacks and uh it's a long tournament
but couldn't ask for a better start of
course no no
something about perfection and a perfect
start is really good
and you pointed out that every time you
got you picked first right why you won
yeah yeah I got that number one and and
I think that's true in my career where
uh and there she she actually won an X
the the bishop F6 move was a very nice
touch because then she won an extra
Tempo uh with H5 hitting the rook and uh
well just accelerating her Pawns
so Bishop F6 Rook G6 H5
once again Rook G4 H6 and I don't know
what harika I mean she's
looking looking definitely not there if
we go back in this game he was the one
who was playing for a win because it was
opposite called a bishop and rook and
game right when she had her King on E6
but only black was could have been
better so yeah and there she extended
her hand is in congratulations
great game by Alexandra yeah great end
game
and we have one game remaining and we do
believe that yep there there I mean
again slow but steady progress uh
we are expecting I think the only reason
Bella continues to play is that as
always Anna is in time trouble and we
know that when you have a few seconds on
the clock you can still blunder right
yeah where there's uh right there's an
opportunity for blunder
um speaking of blundering uh is uh
would you play F5 shirt
is black here and honestly because I
don't want white to play five right yeah
it's five and then I'll go before okay
so F5 sure but
did I just walk right into that no no no
no so after King age four boy King is
stalemated right so if I push B4 right
do you get but do I uh okay with k6 and
Etc right well it's not a match all the
checks on the sixth rank oh never mind
it's not a stalem yes yeah she did play
F5 checks it's only
there's no really way to force a stomach
yeah like please oh no please please
take the Rook at that if you just avoid
capturing The Rook there's no further
checks check on F6 or check on the G7
one move Cheapo one move Cheapo that's
it no no no wait wait instead of Rook A6
didn't she have Rook takes A3
just go one move back she just plays
this is okay three
no
she still needed her opponent and oh no
Rook takes oh
sorry but that really is the cold shower
I mean I don't know if it's a drill
because blood can play like crook people
no it is because I can play it will be
three after
oh my gosh Rook B3
unbelievable oh no oh no because but
you're looking for the stalemate
that's the remarkable thing she's
looking for the sale she just rushed it
yeah oh my goodness
okay but the point was was that the move
F5 check she could have played King F6
Anna would have won routinely but she
allowed her opponent to make a draw with
the the move G it's it's disguised until
you look and you see the King has no
moves and we looked at Perpetual check
but there is none there is no there's no
mad Rook but this is the Mad Rook
situation go ahead take my Rook I have
no moves that would have been a
stalemate and a draw and I would have
had a heart attack
Daniel her husband
you see now you understand I was yeah I
was a team captain I was having a heart
attack you didn't like whatever I was
watching on in time travel
and she had the plenty of time and she
rushed the movie it's just because she
psychologically already resigned yeah
she's won the game yeah mentally
sometimes you turn your mind off when
you've already chalked up the Victory
and I had exact same situation U.S
Women's Championship 2021. I was I'm
completely lost I'm with black it's plus
five right so I psychologically resigned
but I got myself in stalemate and I had
a draw and then you didn't put put it
back you didn't pull back and say hey
wait a minute my Kingston's tell me I
just rushed and then resigned on the
next move
as soon as I made the move I realized I
had a stalemate oh no I wanted to flip
them
oh my oh I can only imagine your
distress oh that's so terrible yeah wow
almir what a missed opportunity that was
I mean
Captain's on our edge of our seats till
the very last moment
yes and it was an incredible idea okay
three draws the game right and well and
as he supported it so it was brilliant
simply brilliant I think wow and
especially with Rook B3 that follows yes
Rook it takes it's like Rook takes A3 my
bad don't worry I'm still winning
[Laughter]
no no and by the way just a Finishing
Touch very importantly here uh
Bella had one last position one last
Cheapo King E6 go ahead uh
promote your pawns go ahead B3 no
Checkmate in one so let me just get your
king out of the way so now I can play B3
yeah and this is white has zero chances
here
visit zero NADA yeah Bella would have
been so happy to have saved this game
because oh my God be fair this game was
a draw most of the game it was a
deserving kind of a draw right it's not
fair result exactly so now we're
expecting it's not fair
it's the cruelest of games actually uh
people think sport is emotional and it
is sport is emotive but in chess you you
you put your heart and soul into a
creation that doesn't go your way
oh you're crushed yeah it's so crushing
and I I think even authors have called
it that uh for years and years Rook E4
check and wherever you go I'm making a
queen and it's protecting my Rook as
well
and she knows it yeah
and it's just it's just we are setting
up for an interview but we'll wait for
this game to finish and there it is
Hardy hand clasp as Anna
takes a victory and when the two ladies
and you know people are going to assault
them the moment they get up did you see
Rook takes A3 and there's going to be a
jaw dropping I think it might be better
for Bella to not know no she had that
yeah yeah but she'll Discover it in time
but Almera is with our sole leader
uh welcome Alexander it seems like you
know we're in Paris you are at home and
you're coming to itchy every day you
just won your second game an incredibly
complicated game and what they move
through case six uh guide us through the
game today just a few key points first
of all why didn't you take Bishop B3 why
did you decide uh to play 96 well I
didn't remember of course anything in
the opening and I I just went for this
opposite colored bishop and game I
decided to play it safe
and I think the position was about equal
probably I mean she could have played
better she missed some tactical small
tactical possibilities like when she
played Rook before a little bit later on
yeah here Rook C3 Rook B6 I think yeah
it's not
I mean here
probably she she wanted to just repeat
the position but I you know I dared to
play on
yes I played rookie three and of course
it's still pretty equal
and I hesitated for a very long time
after Bishop E6 whether to repeat the
position or not here because yes it was
some kind of repetition but I decided to
play on and yes but did you feel that
she lost the thread of the game
uh well it's already pretty like safe
after the pawn moved to E4 I'm not in
danger to lose my Pawn on D6 or at least
it felt pretty safe and I didn't think
that I'm risking anything to play on
till time control and then yeah
immediately uh like um yeah here she let
me take on A6 and even though I mean it
should be holdable I don't know but
somehow
again I thought that if I don't
sacrifice it's going to be more
difficult for me to play because she is
going to take on C4 and I need to defend
and here she needs to defend I didn't
see how to save the position how to save
the game because G5 G5 I'll just show
one line yeah D5 she takes D5 and
probably she means that if she plays
Rook G3 well at least I hope that I can
play D6
G6 is also possible yes C4
uh G6 C3
G7 C2 Bishop F4 E3 Bishop takes history
Rook takes is three King D2 Rook E8 and
then here D7 Rook G8 and H4
I think I'm in time I don't know why it
just shows ah because it's Rook versus
queen okay but King B6 H5 King C7 H6 and
I'm in time to protect the spawn on G7
and yeah it seems that I should be like
winning here
um so it's gonna be like a rook versus
ah I see Rook G2 and King Sivan I don't
know the evolution of this position
should be winning no well I hope so I
mean yeah but still uh but uh it shows
the depth of your calculation and of how
many variations do you see during the
game it's really impressive so I think
that it was a total shock for your
opponent Did You observe uh harika when
you played the move uh Rook A6 no I mean
I think she noticed it and I mean she
took it pretty calmly but again after G5
yeah I don't know what to do what black
should do instead of D5 because my plan
yeah but then I was going to play King
kid too I'm thinking about just playing
king2 and kinky three kinky four and you
know my plan is very very easy and
whether it's holdable or not it's an
interesting question so
that was a very important Victory
Alexandra I know that you shared
well that you want to win this
tournament at least once so well we
still have seven rounds to go but uh
well catch me if you can as I told
before so I hope that you will continue
the your winning streak yeah I hope so
our congratulations Alexandra a very
very nice Victory indeed we especially
liked your finish with Bishop F6 and
Bishop G5 yeah that was a really really
beautiful touch as we take a look at our
standings with all of the games in the
history books right we have a soul
leader Alexandra karstenyuk starting
with two wins lots of victories in the
tournament thus far and we have three
players closely following Nana tegnite
and two Americans Irina crash and Anna
zachowski very very nice indeed with 50
we have harika dronavali Elizabeth pets
and gunai mamazada
and the two ladies who didn't start the
tournament while jeansai abdomalik and
Bella Hotel Nashville and that last game
with Bella I'm still recovering from the
shock of
but uh we'll get we're getting uh guest
in studio to reveal the great reveal and
we'll see if she also is shocked by the
discovery but tell us about the pairings
for round three
tomorrow we have two Indian players
facing each other in Toronto Valley
against Conroe nice Mama Zada will be
playing Costa nuke can Alexandra be
stopped we'll see satonski against pets
right Abdul Malik again somebody's got
away
and Irina crashed against Nana Technica
okay a big big match up there with two
players tied per second that's going to
be Marquis that's uh as once again with
to uh games out of the way this schedule
we have total of nine rounds and the
players will return tomorrow to play
round three and Thursday June 8th
they're going to have a rest day
excellent and then a Sprint to the
Finish four rounds to go
and let's see if we're ready for our
guest in studio not quite yet getting
there getting there
um still a large number of decisive
games no uh oh look at this look at this
looking good for you and Almira but also
looking very good for Sabina yeah hello
Sabrina's showing inside and
understanding
and I believe in my pick
yeah it's a long tournament it really
really is I for sure but I just have to
Lord it over you while I well I have the
chance yeah it may not just either
revenge for disappeared oh my that was
just so terrible watching Anish Gary
just self-destruct and all my picks were
just like well it was pretty disastrous
All Things Considered which game was
your favorite today because we had
Elizabeth pets winning in nightdorf
um problem with Elizabeth's game it was
too perfect everything went a favor yeah
it was just like kind of one-sided
whereas I really felt the game of
Alexandra and harika was back and forth
a really really great tense fight and
this move Rook 86. yeah and
and we already with our guests so we're
going to jump to Almira
welcome Anna
I think we had the reveal
[Laughter]
yes Anna just saw the move aruke three I
showed her because hopefully she didn't
see it during the game I didn't see of
course I would play something
but even after he played yes level
um I was I was looking at all kind of
stalemates and here like in this moment
and I saw this ideas like
oh well congratulations
[Laughter]
yes but I think uh psychologically she
has resigned the game oh my God this is
just unbelievable so it's like how am I
just to say to do to win the game yeah I
had so much luck in this game so like
who oh my God so what it was the another
critical point
in this game what do you think actually
I didn't know what if she would play if
she would play Ruka a E1 I didn't know
exactly what to do when she played
instead of move from uh
yeah
instead of D6 I wasn't sure if she would
but I didn't know what to do after Rook
ae1 so I was calculating lines and I
didn't decide what to do here so so I
think it's a knight G4 and IG folk win
B7 Rook 88 yes I was thinking this but
yes I did in this position computer
evaluator slightly better for white I
thought Oh I thought it was just bad for
me how can defend how can defend porn
well it's just something just play slow
like Windows C6 or some goodness
everyone can be sorry okay yeah it is
just their own evaluation maybe it was
fine for me how did you feel during the
game did you feel confident
now I cannot say just time and just it's
just shocked with this rookie stream of
you can beef your blunder such things
yeah well no no in this situation didn't
like my position anymore and then when
did the tables turn because they think
that Bella over pushed it here no no I
think I think here uh if she would win a
five I think was better much better and
this this I'm not sure if I would do it
more maybe I could just play without a
pawn because I think win end game is bad
for Me Maybe I'm Wrong and I think I was
thinking here maybe not to take porn but
play Something Something Different yeah
just to keep um heavy pieces on the
board because I think wins and game and
stuff for me yeah that we were trying to
analyze this yeah I think it's I didn't
like it I didn't like I was thinking
maybe yes I know I take up one but I
think it's why it has very good chances
to win this one okay so you wanted to
keep the yes yes playing upon down but
and then I think another critical moment
was when Bella played uh A4 so no I
think that's a draw no no okay after
after no after A4 is fine it's still
fine I think no no I think the computer
evaluates I've already already so she
needed to start before she wanted to
play comfortably yes so this so probably
she thought that any move draws here so
after before you made the very strong
move King yeah it's like such an odd
trap yeah exactly so and computer thinks
that you're much better here and we
already yes so then we can come back to
this beautiful
oh my God this is
oh snatch me or why do you do your show
it's not sleep well I think just such
things I think well nowadays the
information you know spread it so
quickly so you would discover it poor
Bella also or your poor husband
I need to call him right away because
you have delay on before you saw this
and does he help you with your
preparations during this event yeah
of course yeah this line here he didn't
help me but yeah like in general he's
always helping me with preparing and so
I I I hope that maybe
so tell me what what should your I do
after such a game or maybe some piece of
advice some piece of advice maybe maybe
a glass of French wine no help no I
think it's a better like swimming pool
Elizabeth just told us that she's
swimming every morning so maybe
yesterday
no but maybe after the game of course I
saw this idea this is not something new
for me I saw this idea so yes before and
like I like studies I like solving
puzzles but this was just completely
like after five hours playing
preparation with such a tense game
we're all like this game shows we have
to play until the very end even if it
looks like
yes to keep your concentration yes yes
keep concentration and like if I will
have a very bad position I will probably
never resign
okay it's a very important lesson for
all of us thank you Anna congratulations
really liked your time management today
they liked your time management today
because they they told us uh horrific
stories about
[Laughter]
on the US team and then they were
worried all the time
no I think like Lewis and talent but I
was not like much in temperature before
so yes uh congratulations once again and
well for you
I think we should remove this position
the only thing I can add Anna is thank
you for your inspiring Victory yes very
well done very well done as we wrap up
today's show let's take a quick view
once again of tomorrow's pairings and
what we can what our viewers can expect
we have all Indian matchup Toronto
Valley against conero very nice Mama
Zada playing the tournament Soul Leader
Alexander Costino can anybody Stop
Alexandria we'll see and as a tonske
will face Elizabeth pets tomorrow
Abdul Malik against hot in Australia
somebody's got away and Irina crash
against looks like a great round three
pairing coming up uh remember everybody
uh tell your friends where you're
hanging out and invite them over and
final thoughts about an eventful finish
I have to say on that yes that was a
very emotional interview and oh well we
have another decisive rounds uh four
games so I think that we keep our 80
percent yes we do I don't know what they
will need to do during The Thinker food
cup but they think that it should cancel
the tournament
overall so I'm looking forward to our
third round and uh well ladies you are
playing incredible chess absolutely
that's the way more they're giving us
such amazing show amazing games
entertaining until the very last drop
thank you everybody
join us tomorrow and uh best of good
nights see you tomorrow
thanks
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited